welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today marks
the first Journal Club episode between
myself and Dr Peter attia for any of you
that are not familiar with Dr Peter
attia he is a medical doctor in MD who
is an expert in all aspects of health
and lifespan he is the author of a
best-selling book entitled outlive which
is a phenomenal resource on all things
Health span and lifespan and he is the
host of the very popular podcast the
drive where he interviews various
experts in all domains of medicine and
scientists as well today Peter and I
hold our first online collaborative
Journal club for those of you that
aren't familiar with what a journal Club
is a journal Club is a common practice
in graduate school and or medical school
whereby students get together to discuss
one or two papers to critique those
papers and to really compare their own
conclusions of those papers with the
conclusions of the authors and to
highlight any key takeaways Peter and I
have been wanting to do a journal club
together are for a very long time and we
decided to do that journal club and to
record it for you so today you will be
sitting in on the first huberman Atia
Journal club by the way it could just
have easily been called the Atia
huberman Journal club and we will
discuss two papers first Peter is going
to discuss a paper on Metformin which is
a drug that many people are interested
in for its potential role in longevity I
want to highlight potential there he's
going to compare that paper to previous
findings on Metformin and by the end of
that discussion he will advise as to
whether or not he himself would take
metformin and whether or not other
people might be well advised or
ill-advised to take Metformin based on
the data in that paper and at this time
then I present a paper which is about
the placebo effect I have to imagine
that most of you have heard of the
placebo effect but what's interesting
about the paper that we discussed today
is that it shows that the placebo effect
can actually follow a dose response so
it's not just all or none it actually is
the case that you can scale the degree
of placebo effect depending on whether
or not you're thinking you're taking low
doses moderate doses or high doses of a
particular drug and the particular drug
that's discussed in the paper that I
cover is nicotine so for those of you
that are interested in cognitive
enhancement by way of pharmacology or
frankly for people who are simply
interested in how our beliefs can shape
our physiology I think you'll find that
discussion to be very interesting so by
the end of today's episode You Will Not
only have learned about two novel sets
of findings one in the realm of
longevity as it relates to metformin and
another in the realm of neurobiology and
placebos or Placebo effects but you will
also learn how a journal Club is
conducted I think you'll see in
observing how we parse these papers and
discuss them even arguing in them at
times that what scientists and
clinicians do is they take a look at the
existing peer-reviewed research and they
look at that peer-reviewed research with
a fresh eye asking does this paper
really show know what it claims to show
or not and in some cases the answer is
yes and in other cases the answer is no
what I know is for certain is that by
the end of today's episode you will
learn a lot of science you'll learn a
lot about health practices some of which
you may want to apply or avoid and
you'll learn a lot about how science and
medicine is carried out before we begin
I'd like to emphasize that this podcast
is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
Helix sleep Helix sleep makes customized
mattresses to give you the best possible
night's sleep now sleep is the
foundation of mental health physical
health and performance when we are
sleeping well and enough mental health
physical health and performance all
stand to be at their best one of the key
things to getting a great night's sleep
is to make sure that your mattress is
tailored to your unique sleep needs
Helix sleep has a brief two minute quiz
that if you go to their website you take
that quiz and answer questions such as
do you tend to sleep on your back your
side or your stomach do you tend to run
hot or cold in the middle of the night
maybe you don't know the answers to
those questions and that's fine at the
end of that two-minute quiz they will
match you to a mattress that's ideal for
your sleep needs I sleep on the dusk at
the usk mattress and when I started
sleeping on a dust mattress about two
years ago my sleep immediately improved
so if you're interested in upgrading
your mattress go to Helix sleep.com
huberman take their two-minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress for you and you'll
get up to 350 off any mattress order and
two free pillows again if interested go
to helixsleep.com huberman for up to 350
off and two free pillows today's episode
is also brought To Us by levels levels
is a program that lets you see how
different foods and behaviors affect
your health by giving you real-time
feedback using a continuous glucose
monitor one of the most important
factors impacting your immediate and
long-term health is the way that your
body manages its blood glucose or
sometimes referred to as blood sugar
levels to maintain energy and focus
throughout the day you want to keep your
blood glucose steady without big Spa
bikes or dips using levels you can
monitor how different types of foods and
different food combinations as well as
food timing and things like exercise
combined to impact your blood glucose
levels I started using levels a little
over a year ago and it gave me a lot of
insight into how specific Foods were
spiking my blood sugar and then leaving
me feeling tired for several hours
afterwards as well as how the spacing of
exercise and my meals was impacting my
overall energy and in doing so it really
allowed me to optimize how I eat what I
eat when I exercise and so on such that
my blood glucose levels and energy
levels are stable throughout the day if
you're interested in learning more about
levels and trying a continuous glucose
monitor yourself go to levels.link
huberman right now levels is offering an
additional two free months of membership
again that's levels.link l-i-n-k slash
huberman to get two free months of
membership and now for my journal Club
discussion with Dr Peter attia Peter so
good to have you here so great to be
here my friend
this is something that you and I have
been wanting to do for a while and it's
basically something that we do all the
time which is to peruse the literature
and find papers that we are excited
about for whatever reason
and oftentimes that will lead to a text
dialogue or a phone call
or both but this time we've opted to
try talking about these papers that we
find particularly exciting in real time
for the first time
as this podcast format first of all so
that people can get some sense of why
we're so excited about these papers we
we do feel that people should know about
these findings
and second of all that it's an
opportunity for people to learn how to
dissect information and think about the
papers they hear about in the news the
papers they might download from PubMed
if they're inclined but also just to
start thinking like scientists and
clinicians and get a better sense of
what it looks like to
pick through a paper The Good The Bad
and The Ugly so we're flying a little
blind here which is fun
um I'm definitely excited for all the
above reasons yeah no this is uh you and
I have been talking about this for some
time and and
um you know actually we used to run a
journal club inside the practice where
once a month one person would um just
pick a paper and you'd go through it in
kind of a formal Journal Club
presentation we've gotten away from it
for the last year just because we've
been a little stretched then I think
it's something we need to resume because
it's uh it's a great way to learn and
it's a skill you know people probably
ask you all the time because I know I
get asked all the time hey what are the
do's and don'ts of interpreting you know
scientific papers is it enough to just
read the abstract
um and you know usually the answer is
well no
um but the how-to is is tougher and I
think the two papers we've chosen today
illustrate two opposite ends of the
spectrum you know you're gonna obviously
talk about something that we're going to
probably get into the technical nature
of the assays the limitations Etc and
the paper ultimately I've chosen to
present although I apologize I'm
surprising you with this up until you
know a few minutes ago is is actually a
very straightforward simple
epidemiologic paper that I think has
important significance I had originally
gone down the rabbit hole on a much more
nuanced paper about ATP binding
cassettes in cholesterol absorption But
ultimately I thought this one might be
more interesting to a broader audience
by the way I got to tell you a funny
story so I had a dream last night about
you
and um in this dream
you were obsessed with making this
certain drink that was like your Elixir
and it had all of these crazy
ingredients in it some tons of
supplements in it but the one thing I
remembered when I woke up because I
forgot most of them I was really trying
so hard to remember them one thing that
you had in it was do
like you had to collect a certain amount
of dew off the leaves every morning to
put into this drink it was so but it was
like just sounds like something that I
would do and and so but here's the best
part you had you had like a thermos of
this stuff that had to be with you
everywhere and all of your clothing had
to be tailored with a special pocket
that you could put the thermos into so
that you were never without the special
Andrew drink and again you know how
dreams when you're having them seem so
logical and real and then you wake up
and you're like
doesn't even make sense like why would
he want the thermos in his shirt like
that I would warm it up like you know
all these but but boy it was a realistic
dream and there were lots of things in
it including Dew special do off the
leaves every morning I love it well it's
not that far from reality I'm a big um
fan of yerba mate I'm drinking it right
now in fact
um in its many forms usually the loose
leaf I don't tend to drink it out of the
gourd my dad's Argentine so that's where
I picked it up I started drinking it
when I was like five years old or
younger which I don't recommend people
do is heavily caffeinated don't drink
the smoked versions either folks I think
those are potentially carcinogenic but
this thing that you describe of of
carrying around the thermos close to the
body
if you are ever in Uruguay or if you
ever spot grown men in a restaurant
anywhere in the world carrying a thermos
with them and to their meals and hugging
it close
chances are they're Uruguayan and
they're drinking yerba mate they drink
it usually after their meals supposed to
be good for your digestion so it's not
that far from from reality I don't carry
the thermos but I do drink mate every
day and um I'm gonna start collecting
dew off the leaves uh just a few drops
every morning
oh my
um some other time we can talk about
dreams recently I've been doing some
dream exploration I've had some
absolutely transformative dreams for the
first time in my life one dream in
particular that has that allowed me to
feel something I've never felt before
and has catalyzed a large number of
important decisions in a way that no
other experience waking or sleep has
ever impacted me and this was drug free
Etc
um and do you think you could have had
that dream we don't have to get into it
if you don't talk about it now but was
there a lot of work you had to do to
prepare for that dream to have taken
place oh yes yeah
um at least uh 18 months of intensive
um analysis type work
um with a very skilled psychiatrist but
I wasn't trying to seed the dream yeah
yeah it was just I I was at a sticking
point with a certain process in my life
and then
I was taking a walk while waking and
realized
that my brain my subconscious was going
to keep working on this I just decided
it's going to keep working on it and
then two nights later I traveled to a
meeting in Aspen and I had the most
profound dream ever where I was able to
sense something and feel something I've
always wanted to feel as so real within
the dream woke up knew it was a dream
and realized this is what people close
to me that I respect have been talking
about but I was able to feel it and
therefore I can actually access this in
my Waking Life it was it was it was
absolutely transformative for me
um anyway sometime I can share more
details with you or the audience but for
now maybe we should talk about these
papers very well
um who should go first
I'm happy to go first this one's this
one's this is a pretty straightforward
paper so so we're going to talk about a
paper titled reassessing the evidence of
a survival advantage in type 2 diabetics
treated with metformin compared with
controls without diabetes a
retrospective cohort study this is by
Matthew Thomas Keyes and colleagues this
was published last fall
um
why is this paper important so this
paper is important because
in 2014 uh banister published a paper
that I think in many ways kind of got
the world very excited about metformin
so it was almost 10 years ago
and I'm sure many people have heard
about this paper even if they're not
familiar with it but they've heard the
concept of the paper and in many ways
it's the paper that has led to the
excitement around the potential for zero
protection with metformin and I should
probably just Define for the audience
what Giro protection means when we think
probably also sorry to interrupt what
metformin is just for the uninformed
that's a great point so I'll start with
the with the latter so metformin is a
drug that has been used for many years
uh depends you know where it was first
approved I think was in Europe
um but you know call it directionally 50
plus years of use as a first line agent
for patients with type 2 diabetes in the
U.S maybe 40 plus years so this is a
drug that's been around forever trade
name glucophage or brand name and uh but
but again it's you know it's a generic
drug today
the mechanism by which metformin works
is debated hotly but what I think is not
debated is the immediate thing that
metformin does which is it inhibits
complex one of the mitochondria so again
maybe just taking a step back so the
mitochondria as everybody thinks of
those as the cellular engine for making
ATP so the most efficient way that we
make ATP is through oxidative
phosphorylation where we take either
fatty acid pieces or a breakdown product
of glucose once it's partially
metabolized to pyruvate we put that into
an electron transport chain and we
basically trade chemical energy for
electrons that can then be used to make
phosphates onto ADP so it's you know you
think of everything you do eating is
taking the chemical energy and food
taking the energy that's in those bonds
making electrical energy in the
mitochondria those electrons pump a
gradient that allow you to make ATP
to give a sense of how Primal and
important this is if you block that
process completely you die so
everybody's probably heard of cyanide
right cyanide is something that is
incredibly toxic even at the smallest
doses cyanide is a complete Blocker of
this process and if my memory serves me
correctly I think it blocks complex four
of the mitochondria I don't know if you
recall if it complex three are complex
four I know a lot about toxins that
impact the nervous system but I don't
know a lot about poison but if ever you
want to have some fun we can talk about
all the dangerous stuff that animals
make and insects make and how they kill
you yeah
prototoxin and all these things that
blocks
I I really geek out on this stuff
because it allows me to talk about
Neuroscience animals and scary stuff
it's like combines it so we could do
that sometime for fun maybe at the end
if we have a few moments so so you know
something like cyanide that is a very
potent inhibitor of this electron
transport chain will kill you instantly
people understand that of course a drop
of Cyanide and you would you would be
dead literally instantaneously yeah
so metformin works at the first of those
complexes I believe there are four if my
memory serves correctly four electron
transport chain complexes and um but of
course it's not a complete inhibition of
it it's just kind of a weak Blocker of
that and the net effect of that is what
so the net effect of that is that it
changes the ratio of adenosine
monophosphate to adenosine diphosphate
um what's less clear is why does that
have a benefit in diabetics because what
it unambiguously does is reduces the
amount of glucose that the liver puts
out so hepatic glucose output is one of
the fundamental problems that's
happening in type 2 diabetes you may
recall I think we talked about this even
on a previous podcast
you and I sitting here with normal blood
sugar have about five grams of glucose
in our total circulation that's it five
grams think about how quickly the brain
will go through that
within minutes
so the only thing that keeps Us Alive is
our liver's ability to titrate out
glucose and if it puts out too much for
example if the glucose can if the
glucose level was consistently two
teaspoons you would have type 2 diabetes
so the difference between being
metabolically healthy and having you
know profound type 2 diabetes is one
teaspoon of glucose in your bloodstream
so the ability of the liver to Tamp down
on high glucose output is important
metformin seems to do that so can I just
ask oh one question is it fair
um to provide this overly simplified
summary of the biochemistry which is
that when we eat the food is broken down
but the breaking of bonds creates energy
that then our cells can use in the form
of ATP and the mitochondria are
essential of that process and that
metformin is partially short-circuiting
the energy production process and so
even though we are eating when we have
metformin in our system presumably there
is going to be less
net glucose the bonds are going to be
broken down we're chewing we're
digesting but less of that is turned
into blood sugar glucose well sort of I
mean it's not
um
it's not depriving you of ultimately
storing that energy what it's doing is
changing the way the body
um partitions fuel that's probably a
better way to think about it to be a
little bit more accurate so
um for example like it's not depriving
you of the calories that are in that
glucose that would be you know fantastic
but that was the that was the uh Electra
remember the Electra from the 90s
Electra folks for those of you don't
remember
um by the way if you ever ate this stuff
you'd remember because it was a fat that
was not easily digested it had sort of
in sort of analogous to plant fiber or
something like that so it was being put
into potato chips and whatnot and the
idea is that people would
um would simply excrete it
um and I don't know what happened except
that people got a lot of stomach aches
and um
in the world we know that the anal
seepage is what really did that product
only a physician
because after all Peter's a clinician
for physician and MD and I'm not
um could find it a um an appropriate
term to describe yeah when you have that
much when you have that much fat
malabsorption you start to have
accidents wow
and so that did away with that product
right it was either that or the diaper
industry was trying to really take off
okay that's why you don't hear about
Electro that's right so so we've got
this drug we've got this drug metformin
it's considered a perfect First Line
agent for people with type 2 diabetes so
again what's happening when you have
type 2 diabetes uh the primary insult
probably occurs in the muscles and it is
insulin resistance everybody hears that
term what does it mean uh insulin is a
peptide it binds to a receptor on a cell
so let's just talk about it through the
lens of the muscle because the muscle is
responsible for most glucose disposal it
gets glucose out of the circulation high
glucose is toxic we have to put it away
and we want to put most of it into our
muscles that's where we store 75 to 80
percent of it
when insulin binds to the insulin
receptor tyrosine kinase is triggered
inside so just ignore all that but a
chemical reaction takes place inside the
cell that leads to a phosphorylation so
ATP donates a phosphate group and a
transporter just think of like a little
tunnel like a little straw goes up
through the level of the cell and now
glucose can freely flow in so I'm sure
you've talked a lot about this with your
audience things that move against
gradients need pumps to move them things
that move with gradients don't glucose
is moving with its gradient into the
cell it doesn't need active transport
but it does need the transporter put
there that requires the energy
that's the job of insulin
by the way I did not know that I mean I
certainly know active and passive
transport as it relates to like
neurotransmitter and ion flow
um but I'd never heard that when insulin
binds to a cell that literally a little
straw is placed into the membrane
glucose doesn't need a pump to move it
in
um because there's much more glucose
outside the cell than inside so it's
just but the energy required is to move
the straw up to the cell so biology is
so cool yeah it is so so what happens is
as and Gerald Shulman at Yale did the
best work on elucidating this as the
intramuscular fat increases and I by
intramuscular I mean intracellular fat
uh triasil and disoglycerides accumulate
in a muscle cell that signal gets
interrupted and all of a sudden I'm
making these numbers up if you used to
need two units of insulin to trigger the
little transporter now you need three
and then you need four and then you need
five you need more and more insulin to
get the thing up that is the definition
of insulin resistance the cell is
becoming resistant to the effect of
insulin and therefore the early Mark of
insulin resistance the canary in the
coal mine is not an increase in glucose
it's an increase in insulin so normal
glycemia with hyperinsulinemia
especially postprandial meaning after
you eat hyperinsulinemia is the thing
that tells you hey you're five ten years
away from this being a real problem
so fast forward many steps down the line
someone with type 2 diabetes has long
passed that system now not only are they
insulin resistant where they just need a
boatload of insulin which is made by the
pancreas to get glucose out of the
circulation but now that system's not
even working well and now they're not
getting glucose into the cell so now
their glucose level is elevated and even
though it's continually being chewed up
and used up because again the brain
alone would account for most of that
glucose disposal
the liver is now becoming insulin
resistant as well and now the liver
isn't able to regulate how much glucose
to put into circulation and it's
overdoing it so now you have too much
glucose being pumped into the
circulation by the liver and you have
the muscles that can't dispose of it and
it's really a vicious brutal Cascade
because the same problem of fat
accumulating in the muscle is now
starting to happen in the pancreas and
now the relatively few cells in the
pancreas called beta cells that make
insulin are undergoing inflammation due
to the fat accumulation within the
pancreas itself and so now the thing
that you need to make more insulin is
less effective at making insulin so
ultimately way way way down the line a
person with type 2 diabetes might
actually even require insulin
exogenously could you share with us a
few of the causes of type 2 diabetes of
insulin resistance I mean one it sounds
like is accumulating too much fat yeah
so energy imbalance would be an enormous
one inactivity or insufficient activity
is probably the single most of important
so when Gerald Shulman was running
clinical trials at Yale they would be
recruiting undergrads to study obviously
because you're typically recruiting
young people and they would you know be
doing these very detailed mechanistic
studies where they would require actual
tissue biopsies so you know you're going
to biopsy somebody's quadriceps and
actually look at what's happening in the
muscle well I remember him telling me
this when I interviewed him on my
podcast he said the most important
criteria of the people we interviewed is
because they were still lean these
weren't people that were overweight but
they had to be inactive you couldn't
have active people in these studies so
exercising is one of the most important
things you're going to do to ward off
insulin resistance but there are other
things that can cause insulin resistance
sleep deprivation has a profound impact
on insulin resistance I think we
probably talked about this previously
but if you you know some very elegant
mechanistic studies where you sleep
deprive people you know you let them
only sleep for four hours for a week
you'll reduce their glucose disposal by
about half
which is I mean that's a staggering
amount you're basically inducing
profound insulin resistance in just a
week of sleep deprivation
hypercortisolemia is another factor and
then obviously energy imbalance so where
when you're when you're accumulating
excess energy when you're getting fatter
if you start spilling that fat outside
of the subcutaneous fat cells into the
muscle into the liver into the pancreas
all those things are exacerbating and
got it okay so enter metformin
first line drug so most of the drugs so
every drug you give a person with type 2
diabetes is trying to address part of
this chain so some of the drugs tell you
to make more insulin that's that's one
of the strategies so here are drugs like
sulfona ureas they tell the body make
more insulin
other drugs like insulin just give you
more of the insulin thing metformin
tackles the problem elsewhere it tamps
down glucose by addressing the glucose
the hepatic glucose output channel glp-1
agonists are another drug they increase
insulin sensitivity initially causing
you to also make more insulin um so
that's ozempic yes yeah and is it true
that berberine is more or less the poor
man's metformin yep okay yeah it's a
from a tree bark it just happens to have
these same properties yeah and by the
way reducing mtor and reducing blood
glucose yeah and Metformin by the way
occurs from a lilac plant in France like
that's where it was discovered so it's
also metformin is also based on a
substance found in nature so you you
need a prescription for metformin you
don't need a prescription for berberine
correct but yeah we can talk about
berberine a little bit later I had a
couple great experiences with berberine
and a couple bad experiences interesting
or green yeah so um
maybe taking one step back from this in
2011 I became very interested in
metformin personally just reading about
it obsessing over it and just somehow
decided like I should be taking this so
I actually began taking metformin I
still remember exactly when I started I
started it in May of 2011 and I realized
that because I was on a trip with a
bunch of buddies we went to the
Berkshire Hathaway shareholder meeting
which is uh you know the Buffett uh
shareholder meeting and uh you know it
was kind of like a fun thing to do and I
remember being so sick the whole time
because I didn't titrate up the dose of
Metformin I just went straight to two
grams a day which is kind of like the
full dose and we went to this is that
characteristic of your approach to
things
yes I think that's safe to say next time
I'll give you a thermos of this Dew that
I collect in the morning
[Laughter]
so I remember being so sick that the
whole time we were in Nebraska or Omaha
I guess I couldn't we went to Dairy
Queen because you do all the Buffett
things when you're there right like I
couldn't have an ice cream at Dairy
Queen you couldn't I mean I could I'm so
nauseous oh because I would say if
you've got metformin in your system
you're going to buffer glucose you could
have four ice cream cones except I
couldn't put I couldn't keep anything
down I mean I was so nauseous so so
clearly metformin has this side effect
initially which is a little bit of
appetite suppression but regardless
that's the story on Metformin there are
a lot of reasons I was interested in it
um I wasn't thinking true zero
protection that term wasn't in my
vernacular at the time but what I was
thinking is hey this is going to help
you buffer glucose better it's got to be
better and this was sort of my first
foray into you know self-experimentation
do you want to Define zero protection
yeah yeah it's a good term geriatric
Giro yeah so so yeah Jiro from from
geriatric old protection so protection
from aging and when we talk about a drug
like metformin or rapamycin or even NAD
NR these things the idea is we're
talking about them as Giro protective to
signal that they are drugs that are not
targeting a specific disease of Aging
for example a pcsk9 inhibitor is sort of
zero protective but it's targeting one
specific pathway which is cardiovascular
disease and dyslipidemia whereas the
idea is a zero protective agent would
Target Hallmarks of Aging there are nine
Hallmarks of Aging please don't ask me
to recite them I've never been able to
get all nines straight but people know
what we're talking about right so
decreased autophagy increased senescence
decreased nutrient sensing or defective
nutrient sensing uh proteomic
instability genomic instability
methylation all of these things
epigenetic changes those are all the
nine Hallmarks of eight to seven yeah
yeah so a zero protective agent would
Target those deep down biologic
Hallmarks of Aging
and in 2014 a paper came out by banister
that basically got the world focused on
this problem by the world I mean the
world of of anti-aging
so what what banister and colleagues did
was they took a registry from the UK and
they got a set of patients who were on
Metformin with type 2 diabetes but only
metformin so these were people who had
just progressed to diabetes they were
not put on any other drug just metformin
and then they found from the same
registry a group of matched controls so
this is a standard way that
epidemiologic studies are done because
again you don't have the luxury of doing
the randomization so you're trying to
account for all the biases that could
Exist by saying we're going to take
people who look just like that person
with diabetes so can we match them for
age sex socioeconomic status
blood pressure BMI everything we can and
then let's look at what happened to them
over time now again this is all
happening in the future so you're
looking into the past it's retrospect in
that sense
and so let me just kind of pull up the
the sort of table here so I can kind of
walk through and this is not in the
paper we talked about but I think this
is an important background so
they did something that at the time I
didn't really notice I didn't notice
what they did I probably did and I
forgot but I didn't notice this until
about five years ago when I went back
and looked at the paper
and they did something called
um uh informative censoring so the way
the study worked is if you were put on
Metformin we're gonna follow you if
you're not on Metformin we're going to
follow you and we're going to track the
number of deaths from any cause that
occurred this is called all-cause
mortality or ACM and it's really the
gold standard in a trial of this nature
or a study of this nature or even a
clinical trial you want to know how much
are people dying from anything because
we're trying to prevent or delay death
of all causes
informative censoring says
if a person
who's on Metformin
deviates from that inclusion criteria we
will not count them in the final
assessment so how are the ways that that
can happen well one the person can be
lost to follow up
two they can just stop taking their
metformin three and more commonly they
can progress to needing a more
significant drug
so all of those patients were excluded
from the study
so think about that for a moment this is
in my opinion a significant limitation
of this study because what you're
basically doing is saying we're only
going to consider the patients who were
on Metformin stayed on Metformin and
never progressed through it and we're
going to compare those to people who
were not having type 2 diabetes so an
analogy here would be imagine we're
going to do a study of two groups that
we think are almost identical one of
them are smokers and the other are
identical in every way but they're not
smokers and we're going to follow them
to see which ones get lung cancer
but every time somebody dies in The
Smoking group we stop counting them
when you get to the end you're going to
have a less significant view of the
health status of that group
so with that caveat the banister study
found a very interesting result which
was the crude death rate
um was and by the way the way these are
done this is also one of the challenges
of epidemiology is the math gets much
more complicated
you have to normalize death rate for the
amount of time you study the people so
everything is normalized to thousand
person years so the crude death rate in
the group of people with type 2 diabetes
who were on Metformin including the
censoring was 14.4 so
14.4 deaths occurred per thousand
patient years
if you look at the control group it was
15.2
this was a startling result and I
remember reading this in again 2014 and
being like holy crap this is really
amazing is there
um could you explain why because I I
hear those numbers and they don't seem
that striking it's a difference of about
a year and a half now of course
um a difference of about a year and a
half in lifespan is is well it is
remarkable it doesn't even translate to
that so so taking a step back type 2
diabetes on average will shorten your
life by six years I see so that's the
Actuarial difference between having type
2 diabetes and not all comers but you're
right this is not a huge difference it's
only a difference of a little less than
one year of Life per thousand patient
years studied okay and by the way up
here just point out my my math was wrong
when I said about a year and a half but
but the point here is you would expect
the people in the metformin group to
have a far worse outcome I.E to have a
far worse crude death rate
and the fact that it was statistically
significant in the other direction and
it turned out on the What's called the
Cox proportional Hazard which is where
you actually model the difference in
lifespan the people who took metformin
and had diabetes had a 15 one five
fifteen percent relative reduction in
all-cause death over 2.8 years which was
the median duration of follow-up well
that seems to be the number that makes
me go wow yeah right that
um because
could you repeat those numbers again yep
so 15 reduction in all-cause mortality
over 2.8 years
that's a big deal it is and again
there's no clear explanation for it
unless you believe that metformin is
doing something Beyond helping you lower
blood glucose
because the difference in blood glucose
between these two people was still in
favor of the non-diabetics
so again the proponents of Metformin
being a zero protective agent and I put
myself in this category at one point I
would put myself today in the category
of undecided but at the time I very much
believed this was a very good suggestion
that metformin was doing other things
you mentioned a couple already metformin
is a weak inhibitor of mtor Metformin
reduces inflammation metformin
potentially tamps down on senescent
cells and their secretory products you
know there are lots of things metformin
could be doing that are off Target
and it might be that those things are
conferring the advantage
as many of you know I've been taking ag1
daily since 2012. so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast ag1 is a
vitamin mineral probiotic drink that's
designed to meet all of your
foundational nutrition needs now of
course I try to get enough servings of
vitamins and minerals through whole food
sources that include vegetables and
fruits every day but oftentimes I simply
can't get enough servings but with ag1
I'm sure to get enough vitamins and
minerals and the probiotics that I need
and it also contains adaptogens to help
buffer stress simply put I always feel
better when I take ag1 I have more focus
and energy and I sleep better and it
also happens to taste great for all
these reasons whenever I'm asked if you
could take Just One supplement what
would it be I answer ag1 if you'd like
to try ag1 go to drinkag1.com huberman
to claim a special offer they'll give
you five free travel packs plus a year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 again that's
drink ag1.com huberman
so fast forward until a year ago and I
think most people took the banister
study as kind of the best evidence we
have for the benefits of metformin and
I'm sure you've had lots of people come
up to you and ask you should I be on
Metformin should I be on Metformin I
mean I probably get asked that question
almost as much as I'm asked any question
outside of do I mean people definitely
want to know if you should be consuming
do but but after that it's metformin
fresh off the leaves has to be while
viewing morning sunlight so okay so
let's so let's kind of fast forward to
now the paper that I wanted to spend a
few more minutes on yeah and thanks for
that background I I'm still uh dazzled
by the uh insertion of the straw by way
of of uh insulin I I don't think I've
ever heard that described I need to I
need to go get a better textbook it's a
pretty Short Straw In fairness you know
it's just it's just a little yeah just
um to give people a sense of why I'm so
dazzled by I am always fascinated by how
quickly
how efficiently and um how specifically
biology can create these little protein
complexes that do something really
important I mean you're talking about an
on-demand creation of a portal right I
mean these are cells engineering their
own Machinery in real time in response
to chemical signals it's great yeah but
I'm I'm sort of Rusty on my Neuroscience
but an action potential Works in reverse
the same way like you need the ATP
gradient to restore the uh to restore
the gradient but once the action
potential fires it's passive outside
right yeah so what peer's referring to
is um the way that neurons become
electrically activist by the flow of
ions across the from the outside the
cell to inside the cell and we have both
active conductances mean they're
triggered by electrical changes in the
gradients Via changes in electrical
potential
um and then their passive gradients
where things can just flow back and
forth until there's a balance equal
inside and outside the cell I think
what's um what's different is that
there's some movement of a lot of stuff
inside of neurons when neurotransmitters
like dopamine bind to its receptor and
then a bunch of you know it's like a
Bucket Brigade that gets kicked off
internally but it's not often that you
hear about receptors getting inserted
into cells very quickly normally you
have to go through a process of of you
know transcribing genes and making sure
that the specific proteins are made and
then those are long slow things that
take place over the course of many hours
or days what you're talking about is a
real on-demand insertion of a channel
and it makes sense as to why that would
be required but it's just oh so very
cool it's cool yeah so keys and
colleagues came along and said we would
like to redo the entire banister
analysis
um and I I think their motivation for it
was the interest in this topic is
through the roof there is a clinical
trial called the tame trial that is I
think pretty much funded now and maybe
getting underway soon the tame trial
which is an important trial is going to
try to ask this question prospectively
and through random assignment so so this
is the targeting aging with metformin
trial that's correct okay near barzilla
uh is probably the senior Pi on that
um and I think in many ways the banister
study along with some other studies
um but of lesser significance probably
provided some of the motivation for the
tame trial so they said okay look we're
going to do this we're going to use a
different cohort of people so the first
study that we just talked about the
banister study used uh I believe it was
like roughly they sampled like 95 000
subjects from a UK biobank here they
used a larger sample they did about half
a million people sampled from a Danish
Health registry and they did something
pretty elegant they created two groups
to study so the first was just a
standard replication of what banister
did which was just a group of people
with and without diabetic that they
tried to match as perfectly as possible
but then they did a second analysis in
parallel with discordant twins so
same-sex twins that only differed in
that one had diabetes and one didn't
I thought this was very elegant because
here you have a degree of genetic
similarity and you have similar
environmental uh factors during
childhood that might give you you know
allow you to see if there's any sort of
difference in signal so now turning this
back into a little bit of a journal Club
virtually any clinical paper you're
going to read table one is the
characteristics of the people in the
study you always want to take a look at
that so when I look at table one here
you can see it's and by the way just for
people watching this we're going to make
all these papers and figures available
so if you're you know don't you know
we'll have nice show notes that'll make
all this clear so table one in the keys
paper shows the Baseline characteristics
and again it's almost always going to be
the first table in a paper usually the
first figure in the paper is a study
design it's usually a flow chart that
says these are the inclusion criteria
these are all the people that got
excluded this is how we randomized Etc
and you can see here that there are four
columns so the the first two are The
Singletons these are people who are not
related and then the second two are the
twins who are matched and you can see
remember how I said they sampled about
500 000 people you can see the numbers
so they got you know
7842 Singletons on Metformin the same
number then they pulled out matched
without diabetes on the twins they got
976 on Metformin with diabetes and then
by definition
976 co-twins without them
and you look at all these
characteristics what was their age upon
entry how many were men what was the
year of indexing when we got them what
medications were they on what was their
highest level of Education marital
status Etc the one thing I want to call
out here that really cannot be matched
in a study like this so this is a very
important limitation is the medication
so look at look at that column Andrew
notice how pretty much everything else
is perfectly matched until you get to
the medication list yeah it's all over
the place yeah it's just you it's not
even close they're not where they're
nowhere near matched right in other
words just to give you a couple of
examples right on the and let's just
talk about The Singletons because it's
basically the same story on the twins if
you look at what fraction of the people
with type 2 diabetes are on lipid
lowering medication it's 45.6 percent
versus 15.4 percent in the Matched
without diabetes it's a 3X difference
what about anti-platelet therapy that's
30 versus 14
antihypertensive 65 percent versus 63
versus 31 because people who have one
health issue and are taking metformin
are likely to have other health issues
exactly so this is again a fundamental
flaw of epidemiology you can never
remove all the confounders this is why I
became an experimental scientist so that
we could control variables that's right
because without random assignment you
cannot control every variable now you'll
see in a moment when we get into the
analysis they go through three levels of
corrections but they can never correct
this medication one so just keep that in
the back of your mind okay so the two
big things that were done in this
experiment or in this survey or you know
study to differentiate it from banister
was one the twin trick which I think is
pretty cool the second thing that they
did
was they did a sensitivity analysis with
and without informative censoring so one
of the things they wanted to know is hey
does it really matter if we don't count
the metformin patients who progress
so
um so let's see kind of what what
transcribed so the next figure figure
two pardon me the next table table two
walks you through the crude uh mortality
rate in each of the groups so the most
important row I think in this table is
the one that says crude mortality per
thousand person years
now you recall that in the previous
study in the banister study those were
on the ballpark of about 15 per okay so
let's look at each of these so in the
um single The Singletons with without so
the non-twins who were not diabetic it
was 16.86 and could you put a little
more Contour on what this thousand
person years what what it is are you
talking about pooling the lifespans of a
of of a bunch of different people until
you get to the number 1000 yeah because
you're normalizing not so it's not who's
going to live a thousand years because
everyone's expecting that
um you're essentially taking so you've
got some people that are going to live
um 76 years 52 years 91 years and you're
pooling all of those until you hit a
thousand and then that becomes kind of a
a a it's like a normalized division
you're basically like so let's say the
the control group
um you're asking if there were a
thousand person years available to live
How likely is it that this person would
live another 15. yeah so a couple ways
to think about it so taking a step back
we always have to have some way of
normalizing so when we talk about the
mortality from a disease is like cancer
in the population we would we report it
as what's the mortality rate per and
it's typically per 100 000 persons
okay that's a much more intuitive way to
express it it is but the reason we can
do it that way is because we're
literally looking at how many people
died this calendar year and we divide it
by the number of people in that age
group so it's typically what you're
doing when you look at aged groups in
buckets of like decades so that's why we
can say the highest mortality is like
people 90 and up even though the
absolute number of deaths is small it's
because there's not that many people
there right the majority of deaths in
absolute terms probably occur in the
seventh decade
but as you go up because the denominator
is shrinking you have to normalize to it
so we just normalized the number of
people here are all the people that
started the year hear all the people
that ended the year what's the death
rate why are these done in a slightly
more complicated way because we we don't
follow these people for their whole
lives we're only following them for a
period of observation in this case
roughly three years
so to say something like you know we
have a crude death rate of five deaths
per thousand person years one way to
think about that is if you had a
thousand people and you followed them
for one year you'd expect five to die
if you had 500 people and you followed
them for two years you expect five to
die
if you have a thousand people and you
follow them for one year you expect five
to die those would all be considered
equivalent mortalities
great thank you for clarifying that no
no this this stuff is I mean like I find
I find epidemiology when you get in the
weeds is way more complicated than
following the basics of
um experimental stuff where you just you
get to push all this stuff into the
garbage bin and just say we're gonna
take this number of people we're gonna
exclude this group we're going to
randomize we're going to see what
happens yeah that's what like the paper
we'll talk about next
so
when you adjust for age and they don't
show it in this table it's only in the
text when you adjust for age a very
important check to do is what is the
crude death rate of the people on
Metformin who are not twins versus who
are twins now in this table
they look different because it's 24.93
for the metformin group and 21.68 for
the twin group in that's on Metformin
when you adjust for age they're almost
identical it's it goes from 29 point
24.93 to 24.7
one other point I'll make here for
people who are going to be looking at
this table is you'll notice there are
parentheses after every one of these
numbers what is that what does that
offer in there those parentheses are
offering the 95 confidence interval so
for example to take the number you know
24.93 is the crude death rate of how
many people are dying who take Metformin
what it's telling you is we're 95
confident that the actual number is
between 23.23 and 26.64
if a 95 confidence interval does not
cross the number zero it's statistically
significant
okay so the first thing that just jumps
out at you I think when you look at this
is there's clearly a difference here
between the people who have diabetes and
those who don't
it complicates the study a little bit
because it's basically two studies in
one but you're comparing
um 95 pardon me uh 24.93 to 16.86 which
by the way remains after age adjustment
when you go to the twin group it's 24.73
to 12.94 so maybe just to zoom out for
that what you're describing if I
understand correctly is this um uh crude
deaths per 1000 person years let's just
talk about The Singletons the non yes is
16.86 so 16.86 people die and some
people probably think how can 0.86 of a
person die well it's not always whole
numbers but
um
there's a there's a bad joke to be made
here but yeah just call it 17 versus 25
right 17 deaths per thousand versus 25
deaths yep and the 25 is in the folks
that took metformin now that to the
naive listener and to me means oh you
know metformin basically kills you right
um not a faster or you know you're more
likely to die but we have to remember
that these people have
another they have a major health issue
that the other group does not have
that's right because people weren't
assigned drug or not assigned drug it
wasn't Placebo drug it's let's look at
people taking this drug for a bad health
issue and compare to everyone else
that's right
so now you have to go into and and I'll
just sort of skip the next figure but
the next figure is a Kaplan Meyer curve
I I think it's actually worth looking at
it because they show up in all sorts of
studies so if you look at figure one
it's a Kaplan Meyer curve
which is a mortality curve so you'll see
these in any study that is looking at
death and this can be prospective
randomized this can be retrospective but
these are always going to show up and I
think it's really worth understanding
what a kaplan-meyer curve shows you so
when the x-axis is always time and on
the y-axis is always the cumulative
survival so it's a curve that always
goes from zero to one one or one hundred
percent and it's always decreasing
monotonically meaning it can only go
down or stay flat it can never go back
up so that's what a cumulative mortality
curve looks like now we're looking at
you're starting at alive and you're
looking at how many people die for every
year that passes that's right
and in each curve there's one on the
left which is the Matched Singletons and
there's a one on the right which are the
discordant twins you have two lines you
have those that were on Metformin with
type 2 diabetes and you have their
matched controls
and in this figure the Matched controls
are the darker lines and the people with
type 2 diabetes on Metformin that's the
lighter line
you'll also notice and I like the way
they've done it here they've got shading
around each one and we should mention
for those that are just listening that
in both of these graphs the downward
trending line from the controls so again
non-diabetic not taking metformin is
above the line corresponding to the
diabetics who are taking metformin
um put
crudely
um
the people who are taking metformin that
have diabetes are dying at a faster rate
for every single year exam and the two
lines do not overlap except at the
beginning when everyone's alive it's
like a foot race where basically the
people with metformin and diabetes are
falling behind and dying as they fall
that's right and I'm glad you brought up
a good point
it's not uncommon in treatments uh to
see kaplan-meyer curbs cross they don't
have to it's not a requirement that they
never cross it's only a a requirement
that they're monotonically decreasing or
staying flat so I've seen cancer
treatment drugs where they have like two
drugs going head-to-head in a cancer
treatment and like one starts out
looking really really bad but then all
of a sudden it kind of flattens well the
other one goes bad and then it actually
crosses and goes underneath but that's
not the case here so to your point the
people with diabetes taking metformin in
both the match Singletons and the
discordants are dropping much faster and
they always stay below and I was just
going to say that the shading is just
showing you a 95 confidence interval so
you're just putting basically error bars
along this so if this were experimental
data if you were doing an experiment
with
a group of mice and you were watching
their survival and you were you know
what you'd have error bars on this which
you're actually measuring so this is
because you have much more data here
you're just showing this in this fashion
for those that haven't um been
familiarized statistics no problem um
error bars correspond to like if you're
just going to measure the heights of a
room full of 10th graders there's going
to be a range right you'll have the very
tall kid and the and the Very uh shorter
kid and you know the short kid and the
medium kit and you'll and so there's a
range there's gonna be an average a mean
and then there'll be standard deviations
and standard errors and um uh so these
confidence intervals just give a sense
of how much range you know some people
um die die early some people dilate
within a given year they're going to be
different ages
um so it these error bars can account
for a lot of different forms of
variability here you're talking about
the variability is how many people in
each group die we're not tracking one
diabetic taking metformin versus a
control I I should have asked this
earlier earlier but well and it's also a
mathematical model at this point too
that's smoothing it out because notice
it's running for the full eight years
even though they're only following
people for you know typically I think
the median was like three or four years
at a time so they're using this quite
complicated type of mathematics called A
Cox proportional Hazard which is what
generates Hazard ratios and basically
any model has to have some error in it
and so they're basically saying this is
the error so you could argue when you
look at that figure we don't know
exactly where the line is in there but
we know it's in that shaded area
if those shaded areas overlapped you
couldn't really make the conclusion you
wouldn't know for sure that one is
different from the other yeah that's
actually a good opportunity to um to uh
raise a common myth which is a lot of
people when they look at a paper let's
say it's a bar graph you know
um and they see these error bars and
they will say people often think oh if
the error bars overlap it's not a
significant difference but if the error
bars don't overlap meaning there's
enough separation then that's a real and
meaningful difference and that's not
always the case it depends a lot on the
form of the experiment
um I often see some of the the more
robust Twitter battles over you know how
people are reading graphs and I think
it's important to remember that
um you run the statistics hopefully the
correct statistics for the for the
sample but determining significance
whether or not the the result could be
due to something other than chance of
course
your confidence in that increases as it
becomes typically p-values P less than
point zero zero zero zero one percent
chance that it's due
um chance right so very low probability
P less than 0.05 tends to be the kind of
gold standard cut off
um but when you're talking about data
like these which are repeated measures
over time people are dropping out
literally
um over time you're saying they've
modeled it to make predictions as to
what would happen we're not necessarily
looking at you know raw data points here
yeah the raw data was in the previous
table that's now taken and run through
this Cox model and it's smoothed out got
it and to your point about the bar
graphs yeah I think the other thing you
always want to understand is just
because something doesn't achieve
statistical significance
the only way you can say it's not
significant is you have to know what it
was powered to detect
um and statistical power is a very
important concept that probably doesn't
get discussed enough but before you do
an experiment you have to have an
expectation of what you believe the
difference is between the groups and you
have to determine the number of samples
you will need to assess whether or not
that difference is there or not so you
use something it's called a power table
and you you would go to the power table
so if you if you're doing treatment a
versus treatment B and you say look I
think treatment a is going to have a 50
response and I think treatment B will
have a 65 percent response you literally
go to a power table that says 50
response 15 difference that gives you a
place on the grid and I want to be 90
sure that I'm right so 90 power I'm
being a little bit so there's going to
be a statistician listening to this
who's going to want to kill me but this
is directionally the way we would
describe it and that tells you this is
how many animals or people you would
need in this study you're going to need
147 in each group and by the way if you
now do the experiment with 147 and you
fail to find significance you can
comfortably say there is no statistical
difference at least up to that 15
percent there may be a difference at 10
but you weren't powered to look at 10
percent yeah and um very important point
that you're making another Point that's
just uh more General one about
statistics in general the way to reduce
variability in a data set is to increase
sample size and that kind of makes sense
right if you if I just walk into a 10th
grade class and okay I'm going to
measure height and I'd buy the first
three kids that I see and I happen to
look over there and it's the three that
all play on the volleyball team together
I my sample size is small and I'm likely
to get a skewed representation in this
case taller than average so increasing
sample size tends to decrease variation
so the that's why when you hear about a
study from the UK biobank or from you
know half a million Danish citizens like
for instance in this study that's those
are enormous sample sizes so even though
this is uh not an experimental study
it's an epidemiological observational
study
um there's tremendous Power by way of
the enormous number of subjects and
that's the way that epidemiology will
make up for its deficit so you could
never do a randomized assignment study
on half a million people
um you know so so
epidemiology makes up for its biggest
limitation which is it can never
compensate for inherent biases by saying
we can do infinite duration if we want
like we could we could survey people
over the course of their lives and we
can have the biggest sample size
possible because this is relatively
cheap the cost of actually doing an
experiment where you have tens of
thousands of people is prohibitive I
mean if you look at the women's health
initiative which was a five-year study
on I don't know what was it 50 000 women
I mean was a billion dollar study so
this is this is The Balancing Act
between epidemiology and randomized
prospective experiments and uh they so
they both offer something but you just
have to know their blind spots of each
one
I'd like to take a quick break and
acknowledge our sponsor inside tracker
inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
meet your health goals I'm a big
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test
however with a lot of blood tests out
there you get information back about
blood lipids about hormones and so on
but you don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
have a personalized platform that makes
it very easy to understand your data
that is to understand what those lipids
what those hormone levels etc mean and
behavioral supplement nutrition and
other protocols to adjust those numbers
to bring them into the ranges that are
ideal for your immediate and long-term
Health Insight tracker's ultimate plan
now includes measures of both APO B and
of insulin which are key indicators of
cardiovascular health and energy
regulation if you'd like to try inside
tracker you can visit insidetracker.com
huberman to get 20 off any of inside
trackers plans again that's inside
tracker.com huberman to get 20 off
so let's just kind of wrap this up I
mean I think let's just go to table four
which I think is the most important
table
um in in here which now lays out the the
final results in terms of the hazard
ratio so this is this is the way we want
to really be thinking about this so
again Hazard ratios
um these are important things to
understand a hazard ratio is a number
and you always subtract one from the
hazard ratio and that tells you if it's
a positive number if it's a number sorry
if it's a number greater than one you
subtract one and that tells you the
relative harm so if it has a ratio is
1.5 you subtract 1.5 is a 50 increase in
Risk
um if the number is negative you may
recall on the banister paper the hazard
ratio was 0.85 so if it's nothing so
that means it's a 15 reduction in
relative risk and here you can see all
the hazard ratios are positive so what
it's telling you here is and I'm going
to walk through this because it's
there's a lot of information packed here
you've got Singletons you've got twins
they're showing you three different ways
that they do it they do an unadjusted
model if you just look at The Singletons
with and without metformin and you make
no adjustments the hazard ratio is 1.48
meaning the people on Metformin had a 48
greater chance of dying in any given
year than their non-diabetic counterpart
the only reason I'm smiling it's not
because I enjoy people dying quite quite
to the contrary is that
um this is novel for me that I've read
some epidemiological studies before but
it's not normally where I spend the
majority of my time but up until now I
was thinking okay people taking
metformin are dying more more than those
that aren't I just and I I'm just
relieved to know that I wasn't um
looking at all this backwards okay so
they're dying more but of course we
don't have a group that's taking
metformin who doesn't have diabetes and
we don't have a group
um who uh
has diabetes and you know is taking
metformin plus something else so again
we're only dealing with these
constrained yeah now there's a lot of
other arm to this study that I'm not
getting into because it adds more
complexity which is they also have
another group that's got diabetes takes
metformin and takes sulfona ureas which
is a bigger drug and those people die
even more whoa so which again speaks to
the point right the more you need these
medications they're never able to erase
the effect of diabetes but in this case
it seems that they might be accelerating
possibly accelerating death due to
diabetes possible we could never know
that from this because we're we don't
see we would need to see diabetics who
don't take Metformin who take nothing
and I would bet that they would do even
worse
so my intuition is that the metformin is
helping but not helping nearly as much
as we thought before so my point is they
make another set of adjustments they say
okay well look in the first one in the
unadjusted model we only matched for age
and gender
okay that's pretty crude what if we
adjust for the medications they're on
the cardiovascular psychiatric pulmonary
dementia meds and marital status I don't
know why they threw marital status in
there but they did I don't know maybe
being married or unmarried I'm sure but
it just seems like a random thing to
throw in with all their meds I would
have personally done that adjustment
higher up but nevertheless if you do
that all of a sudden the uh Hazard ratio
drops from 1.48 to 1.32 which means yep
you still have a 32 percent greater
chance of dying in any given year
all right what if we also adjust for the
highest level of Education along with
any of the other covariates well that
doesn't really change it at all it ends
up at 1.33 or a 33 chance increase in
depth okay I always knew that more
school wasn't going to save me was it's
not doing jack so now let's do it for
the twins if you do the twin study which
you could argue is a slightly pure study
because you at least have one genetic
and environmental thing that you've
attached the unadjusted model is brutal
2.15 that's a hundred and fifteen
percent think about this these are twins
who in theory are the same in every way
except one has diabetes and one doesn't
and the one with diabetes on Metformin
still has 115 percent greater chance of
dying than the non-diabetic co-twin when
you make that first adjustment of all
the meds and marital status you bring it
down to a 70 increase in risk and when
you throw education in it goes up to an
80 chance of risk
now they did this really cool thing
which was they did the analysis on with
and without censoring so everything I
just said here was based on no censoring
tell me about censoring censoring is
when you stop counting the metformin
people who have died
Okay so
in the Singleton group
when you unadjust it and the reason I'm
doing the unadjusted is that's where
they did the sensitivity analysis I
don't think it really matters that much
it's you just have to draw a line in the
sand somewhere you'll recall that that
was a 48 chance of increased mortality
all-cause mortality if you stop counting
if you if you apparently if you don't
censor meaning if you include everybody
including when people on Metformin with
diabetes die if you censor them it comes
down to 1.39
in other words this is a very important
finding it did not undo the benefits
that we saw in the banister study
banister saw a 15 reduction in mortality
when they censored
when Keys censored
it got better but not that much better
it went from 48 to 39 in the twins it
went from a hundred and fifteen percent
down to only 97 percent
so in some ways this presents a little
bit of an enigma
because it's not entirely clear to me
having read these papers many times
exactly why banister found such an
outlined like such a different response
there's another there's another
technical detail of this paper which is
they you can see on the right side of
table four they did something called a
nested case control
but you'll see and I was going to go
into a long explanation of what nested
case controls are it's another pretty
elegant way to do case control studies
where you sample by year and you you you
sort of normalize you you don't count
all the cases at the end you count them
one by one I don't think it's worth
getting into Andrew because it doesn't
change the answer you can see it changes
it just slightly but it doesn't change
the point the point here is the keys
paper makes it undeniably clear that in
that population there was no Advantage
offered by metformin that undid the
disadvantage of having type 2 diabetes
this does not mean that metformin wasn't
helping them because we don't know what
these people would have been like
without metformin it could be that this
bought them a 50 reduction in relative
mortality to where they'd been but what
it says is
in my way this is what you would have
expected this is what you would have
expected 10 years ago before the
banister paper came out or maybe even
before metformin was used because in
some ways it's saying
um what is the likelihood that sick
people who are on a lot of medication
are going to die compared to not sick
people who aren't on a lot of medication
yep wanna you know it's not quite that
simple in the in the sense that as you
said there are ways to
um try and isolate the metformin
contribution somewhat
um because they're on a bunch of other
meds
um and presumably that was done and
analyzed in in other figures that where
they they can sort of try and they can
never attach the results specifically to
metformin right but um there must be
some way of waiting the percentage that
are on psychiatric meds or not on
psychiatric medicine some way to tease
out whether or not there's actually some
contribution to metformin to this result
well that's what they're doing in in be
in the in the partial adjustment is
they're actually com they're actually
doing their best to say oh right married
or not married they're going variable
drug by drug all the way through high
blood pressure non-high blood pressure
smoking non-smoking Etc right and the
way they would do that presumably is
um by saying okay married not married
that's why that's a simple one
um are you on lipid lowering meds yes or
no okay you are not you are not they and
then comparing those groups yeah yeah
okay so no no differences jumping out
that can be purely explained by these
other variables yes although again this
is a this is a great opportunity to talk
about why no matter how slick you are no
matter how slick your model is you can't
control for everything there's a reason
that to my knowledge virtually every
study that compares meat eaters to
non-meat eaters finds an advantage
amongst the non-meat eaters
and we can talk about lifespan Advantage
yes and we can or disease you know
incidence uh studies and yeah it might
be tempting to say well therefore eating
meat is bad
um Until you realize that it takes a lot
of work to not eat meat that's a very
very significant decision that a person
for most people that's a very
significant decision a person makes and
for a person to make that decision they
probably have a very high conviction
about the benefit of that to their
health
and it is probably the case that they're
making other changes with respect to
their health as well that are a little
more difficult to measure now there's a
million other problems with that I
picked a silly example because the whole
meat discussion then gets into well you
know when when we say eating meat what
do we mean like this document is like
deli meat versus grass-fed exactly you
know a deer that you hunted with your
bow how do we get into all those things
but my point is it's very difficult to
quantify some of the intangible
differences and I think that even a
study that goes to Great Lengths as this
one does epidemiologically to make these
Corrections can never make the
corrections and so for me the big
takeaway of this study is one
this makes much more sense to me than
the banister paper which never really
made sense to me and again I was first
critical of the banister paper in 2018
about four years after it came out
that's about the time I stopped taking
metformin by the way I stopped taking it
for a different reason which we can talk
about in a sec but
um that was the first time I went back
and said wait a minute this information
this this informative censoring thing is
that's a little fishy and I think we
weren't looking at a true group of real
type 2 diabetics now that said maybe it
doesn't matter in other words maybe and
even the keys paper doesn't tell us that
metformin wouldn't be beneficial because
it could be that those people if they
were on nothing as their matched cohorts
were on nothing would have been dying at
you know a hazard ratio of three and
this brought it down to 1.5 in which
case you would say there is some zero
protection there it is putting the
brakes on this process
all of this is to say absent a
randomized control trial we will never
know the answer
has there been a randomized control
trial
not when it comes to a hard outcome now
there has been in the ITP so the
interventions testing program uh which
is kind of the gold standard for animal
uh studies which is run out of three
Labs so it's it's an nih-funded program
that's run out of three labs they
um they basically test molecules for
zero protection
um the ITP was the first study that
really put rapid mice on the map in 2009
that was the study that's fortuitously
demonstrated that even when ravamycin
was given very very late in life it was
given to 60 month old mice it still
afforded them a 15 uh lifespan extension
has a similar style you've been done in
humans I mean it's hard I mean it's a
hard no I mean you can't really control
with rapper mice no
um but when the ITP studied metformin it
did not succeed
so the the there have not been that many
drugs that have worked in the ITP the
IDP is very rigorous right it's a it
doesn't use an inbred strain of mice it
is done concurrently in three Labs with
very large sample sizing and so when
something works in the ITP it's pretty
exciting rapamycin has been studied
several times it's always worked another
one we should talk about at a subsequent
time is 17 Alpha estradiol this
continues to work in male mice and it
produces comparable effects to rapamycin
estrogen doesn't work in female rights
but this is Alpha not beta
so this is 17 Alpha estradiol not beta
estradiol which is the estradiol that we
all that is bioavailable in all of us
and and uh just as a brief aside
um I think you and I
basically agree that
um unless it's a problem
males we're talking post-puberty
um should try and have their estrogen as
high as possible without having negative
symptomology because of the importance
of estrogen for libido for brain
function tissue bone health bone health
body because this idea of crushing
estrogen and raising testosterone is
just silly right there's not and let's
just leave raising testosterone out of
it but
many of the approaches to raising
testosterone that are pharmacologic in
nature also raise estrogen a lot of
people try and push down on estrogen and
that is just again unless people are
getting um hyperestrogenic effects like
gynecomastia or other issues is the
exact wrong direction to go you want
estrogen estrogen is a very important
hormone for men and women
um canaga flows in an sglt2 inhibitor
also very successful in the ITP but
again interestingly rapid metformin not
so metformin has failed in the ITP so
you no longer taking metformin I stopped
five years ago I mean you're not a
diabetic so presumably you're taking I
was taking it for a durable protection
to buffer blood glucose yeah and
ultimately potentially live longer yes
exactly and the reason I stopped and
this will be the last thing before we
move on well because you couldn't go to
the Dairy Queen at the Buffett event no
finally the nausea went away after a few
weeks or a month maybe
um but once I got really into lactate
testing I noticed how high my lactate
was
uh at rest so a resting fasted lactate
should be in a healthy person should be
below one like somewhere between 0.3.6
millimole and only when you start to
exercise should lactate go up and in
2018 was when I started blood testing
for my zone two so previously when I was
doing zone two testing I was just going
off my power meter and heart rate but
this is when this is after I met Inigo
San Milan and I started
like wanting to use the lactate
threshold of two millimole as my as my
determinant of where to put my wattage
on the bike
and I'm like
doing finger Pricks before I start and
I'm like 1.6 millimole and I'm like what
the hell is going on I can't be 1.6 but
ran the a flight of stairs up the back
of the Empire State Building well no
that would put me a lot higher right but
but and and being generous to your
Fitness no but but but that's when I
started digging a little digging and
realized oh you know what this totally
makes sense if you have a weak
mitochondrial toxin what are you going
to do you're gonna shunt more glucose
into pyruvate and more pyruvate into
lactate I'm I'm anaerobic yeah fuel
source that's right
so and then my zone two numbers just
seemed off my lactation could you feel
it sorry I didn't know can you feel it
in your body because maybe now I'll just
briefly describe I took berberine
um
I um During the period of maybe
somewhere in the 2012 to 2015 stretch I
don't recall what are you taking it for
well I'll tell you so I I was and I
still am a big fan of Tim ferriss's uh
slow carbohydrate diet because I like to
eat meat and vegetables and starches I'm
an omnivore
um and I found that it worked very
quickly got me very lean I could
exercise I could think I could sleep all
you know a lot of my rationale for
following one eating regimen or another
what I eat is to enjoy myself but also
have mental energy I mean because if I
can't sleep at night I'm not going to
replenish I'm not I don't replenish I'm
gonna feel like garbage I don't care how
lean I am or what you know
um so I found the Slow Carb Diet to be
um which was in the four hour body to be
a very good plan for me it's pretty easy
you drop some things like bread Etc you
don't drink calories except after a
resistance training session Etc but one
day a week you have this so-called cheat
day and on the cheat day anything goes
and so I would eat you know eight
croissants and then I'd alternate to
sweet stuff and then I go to a piece and
by the end of the day you don't want to
look at an item of food at all so the
only modification I made to this slow
carb diet for our body thing was the day
after the cheat day I wouldn't eat I
would just fast and I had no problem
doing that because it was just basically
well since you said um uh what was it
anal um analc was I did not have that
but since you said that I um I won't up
the ante here but I'll at least match
your anal seepage comment by saying I
had let's just call it profound gastric
distress after eating like that the next
day so the last thing you want to do is
eat any food I'll just hydrate and
oftentimes to try and get some exercise
um and what I read was that berberine
Poor Man's metformin could buffer blood
glucose and in some ways make me feel
less sick when ingesting all these
calories in in many cases um spiking my
my blood sugar and Insulin
um because you're having ice cream and
you know Etc and indeed it worked so if
I took berberine and I don't recall the
milligram count and then I ate you know
12 donuts I felt fine it was as if I had
eaten one donut wow I felt sort of okay
in my body and I felt much much better
now
um presumably because it's buffering the
spikes in blood sugar I wasn't crashing
in the afternoon nap and that whole
thing
and do you remember how much you were
taking I think it was a couple hundred
milligrams does that sound about right
um there's a bright yellow capsule
um I forget the source but in any case
one thing I noticed was that if I took
berberine and I did not ingest a
profound number of carbohydrates very
soon afterwards I got brutal headaches I
think I was hypoglycemic I didn't
measure it but I just felt I had
headaches I didn't feel good and then I
would eat a pizza or two and feel fine
and so I realized that berberine was
putting me on this kind of lower blood
sugar state that was the logic anyway
and it allowed me to eat these cheat
Foods
um but when I cycled off of the the four
out because I I don't follow the slow
carbide anymore although I might again
at some point
um when I stopped doing those cheat days
uh I didn't have any reason to take the
berberine and I feared that I wasn't
ingesting enough carbohydrates in order
to really justify trying to buffer my
blood glucose also my blood glucose
tends to be did you ever did you ever
try a carbos no what is that so A carbos
is another glucose disposal yeah it's
actually a drug that but it works more
in the gut and it just prevents glucose
absorption uh a carbos is another one of
those drugs that actually found a
survival benefit in the ITP and it was a
very interesting finding because the
the thesis for testing it the ITP is a
very clever system anybody can nominate
a candidate to be tested then the you
know the panel over there reviews it and
they decide Yep this is interesting
we'll go ahead and study it so when I
think David Allison
nominated uh a car bus to be studied the
rationale was it would be a caloric
restriction mimetic because you would
literally just fail to absorb I don't
know make up some number right 15 to 20
percent of your carbohydrates would not
be absorbed and therefore you would the
mice would effectively be calorically
restricted it would pass them out that's
right and
what happened was really interesting one
the mice lived longer on a carbos but
two they didn't weigh any less
so it what it they lived longer but not
through calorie restriction that's
interesting yes and it the the
speculation is they lived longer because
they had lower glucose in lower insulin
and I don't want to send this down some
rabbit holes here but there are all
sorts of interesting ideas about
um for instance that some forms of
dementia might be so-called type 3
diabetes the diabetes of the brain and
so things like berberine metformin
lowering blood glucose ketogenic diets
Etc might be beneficial there I mean
there's a lot to explore here and I know
you've explored a lot of that on your
podcast I've done far less of that but
well at least it seems that we know the
following things for sure one you don't
want insulin too high nor too low you
don't want blood glucose too high nor
too low if the buffering systems for
that are disrupted clearly exercise
meaning regular exercise is the best way
to keep that system in check but in the
absence of that tool or I would say in
addition to that tool is there any
glucose disposal agent because that's
what we're talking about here metformin
berberine a carbocy etc that you take on
a regular basis because you have that
much confidence in it the only one that
I take is an sglt2 inhibitor
um so this is a class of drug that is
used by people with type 2 diabetes but
which I don't have but because of my
faith in the mechanistic studies of this
drug coupled with its results in the ITP
coupled with the human trial results
that show profound benefit in
non-diabetics taking it even for heart
failure I think there's something very
special about that drug I've actually
that was another paper I was thinking
about presenting this time maybe we'll
do that the next time but do you believe
in caloric
restriction as a way to extend life or
are you more of the
do the right behaviors and that's
covered in your book outlive and
Elsewhere on your podcast
um and buffer blood glucose is do you
still obviously you believe in buffering
blood glucose in addition to just doing
all the right behaviors yeah I think you
can uncouple a little bit the buffering
of blood glucose from the caloric
deficit so
um I think you can be in a reasonable
energy balance and buffer glucose with
good sleep hygiene lots of exercise and
just thoughtful eating without having to
go into a calorie deficit so you know
it's not entirely clear if profound
caloric restriction would offer a
survival advantage to humans even if it
were tolerable to most which it's not
right so for most people it's just kind
of off the table right like if I said
Andrew you need to eat 30 fewer calories
for the rest of your life I'll live 30
fewer Years thank you yeah like there's
just not many people who are willing to
sign up for that so it's kind of a moot
point
um but the question is you know do you
need to be fasting all the time do you
need to be doing all of these other
things and the answer appears to be
outside of using them as tools to manage
energy balance it's not clear right an
energy balance probably plays a greater
role in glucose homeostasis then from a
nutrition standpoint then the individual
constituents of the meal
um now that's not entirely true like I
can imagine a scenario where a person
could be in a negative energy balance
eating Twix bars all day and drinking
you know big gulps but I also don't
think that's a very sustainable thing to
do because if by definition I'm going to
put you in negative energy balance
consuming that much crap I'm gonna
destroy you like you're gonna feel so
miserable you're going to be starving
right you're not going to be satiated
eating pure garbage and being in caloric
deficit you're going to end up having to
go into caloric excess so that's why
it's an interesting thought experiment I
don't think it's a very practical
experiment for a person to be generally
satiated and an energy balanced they're
probably eating about the right stuff
but I don't think that the specific
macros matter as much as I used to think
I'm a Believer in getting most of my
nutrients from
unprocessed or minimally processed
sources simply because it allows me to
eat Foods I like yeah and more of them
and I just love to eat I I so physically
enjoy the sensation of chewing that you
know I'll just eat cucumber slices for
prefer fun yeah right you know that's I
mean that's not my only form of fun
fortunately
um this is an amazing paper
um for the simple reason that it
provides a wonderful tutorial of the
benefits and drawbacks of this type of
work and I think it's also wonderful
because we hear a lot about metformin
rapamycin and um these anti-aging
approaches but
I was not aware that there was any study
of such a large population of people so
it's pretty interesting yeah so I think
it remains to be seen if and my patients
often ask me hey should I be on
Metformin and I give them a much much
much much shorter version of what we
just talked about and I say look if the
tame study which should answer this
question more definitively right this is
taking a group of non-diabetics and
randomizing them to Placebo versus
metformin and studying for specific
disease outcomes if the tame study ends
up demonstrating that there is a zero
protective benefit of Metformin I'll
reconsider everything right so I think
that's you know we just have to I think
all walk around with an appropriate
degree of humility around what we know
and what we don't know but but I would
say right now the epidemiology the
animal data my own personal experience
with its impact on my lactate production
and exercise performance we could
there's a whole other rabbit hole we
could go down another time which is the
impact on hypertrophy and strength which
appears to be attenuated as well by
metformin
um you know I'll I'll
I still prescribe it to patients all the
time if they're insulin resistant for
sure it's still a valuable drug but I
don't think of it as a great tool for
the person who's insulin sensitive and
exercising a lot
can't help but ask this question
do you think there's any longevity
benefit to short periods of caloric
restriction
um you know so for instance I decide to
by the way I haven't done this but let's
say I were to decide to you know fast
and do a one meal a day type thing where
I'm going to be in a slight caloric
deficit you know 500 to 1000 calories
for a couple of days and then go back to
eating
um the way that I eat before that short
caloric restriction slash fast is there
any benefit to it in terms of cellular
Health can you you know so reset the
system is there any idea that the the
changes the clearing of senescent cells
that we hear about autophagy that we you
know that in the short term you can
glean a lot of benefits and then go back
to to your regular pattern of eating and
then periodically you know once every
couple of weeks or once a month just you
know fast for a day or two is there any
benefit to that that's that's purely in
the domain of longevity not because
there's all discipline function there
there's a flexibility function there's
probably an insulin sensitivity function
but is there any evidence that it can
help us live longer I think the short
answer is no
um
for two reasons one I don't think that
that duration would be sufficient if if
one is going to take that approach but
two
um even if you went with something
longer like what I used to do right I
used to do seven days of water only per
quarter three days per month so I was
but I was basically always like it would
be three day fast three day fast seven
day fast just imagine doing that all
year rotating rotating routing for many
years I did that
um now I certainly believed and to this
day I would say I have no idea if that
provided a benefit but my thesis was the
downside of this is relatively
circumscribed which is
profound misery for a few days and what
I didn't appreciate the time which I
obviously now look back at and realize
is muscle mass lost you're just it's
very difficult to gain back the muscle
cumulatively after all of that loss but
my thought was exactly as you said like
there's got to be a resetting of the
system here this must be sufficiently
long enough to trigger all of those
systems but
you're getting at a bigger problem with
geoscience which I'm really hoping the
epigenetic field comes to the rescue on
it has not come close to it to date
which is we don't have biomarkers around
true metrics of Aging
everything we have to date stinks so
we're really good at using molecules or
interventions for which we have
biomarkers right like when you lift
weights
you can look at how much weight you're
lifting you can look at your dexa scan
and see how much muscle mass you're
generating like those are biomarkers
those are giving you outputs that say my
input is good or my input needs to be
modified when you take a sleep
supplement you can look at your eight
sleep and go oh my sleep is getting
better like there's a biomarker
um
when you take Metformin when you take
rapamycin when you fast we don't have a
biomarker that gives us any insight into
whether or not we're moving in the right
direction and if we are are we taking
enough
just don't know
so I I often get asked like what's the
single most important topic you would
want to see more research dollars put to
in terms of this space and it's
unquestionably this as unsexy as it is
like who cares about biomarkers but like
without them I don't think we're going
to get great answers because you can't
do
most of the experiments you and I would
dream up
got it well
I'm grateful that you're sitting across
the table for me telling me all this and
that um everyone can hear this but again
we will put a link to the papers plural
that Peter just described and for those
of you that are listening and not
watching
um hopefully you were able to track the
the general themes and takeaways and it
is fun to go to these papers you see
these big stacks of numbers and and it
can be a little bit overwhelming but
um my uh additional suggestion on
parsing papers is
notice that Peter said that he spent you
know he's read it several times
unlike a newspaper article or or a
Instagram post with a paper you're not
necessarily going to get it the first
time you certainly won't get everything
so that I I think spending some time
with papers for me means reading it and
then reading it again a little bit later
or tell me yeah I was just about to say
what's your because because I kind of
have a way that I do it but I'm curious
as to how you do it like if you're if
you're encountering a paper for the
first time what do you have an order in
which you like to go through the do you
want do you read it sequentially or do
you look at the figures first I mean how
do you how do you go through it yeah
unless it's an area that I know very
very well where I can
you know Skip to some things um before
reading it the whole way through
um my process is always the same and
actually this is fun because I used to
teach a class when I was a professor at
UC San Diego
um called neural circuits and health and
disease and it was an evening course
that grew very quickly from 50 students
to 400 plus students and we would do
exactly this we would parse papers and
um and I had everyone ask
what I called the four questions
um and it wasn't exactly four questions
but I have a little three by five card
next to me or a piece of main map by 11
paper typically and when I sit down with
a paper I want to figure out what is the
question they're asking what's the
general question what's the specific
question and I write down the question
then what was the approach you know how
did they test that question and
sometimes that can get a bit detailed
you can get into immunos chemistry and
they did a you know PCR for this it it's
not so important for most people that
they understand every method but it is
worthwhile that if you encounter a
method like PCR or
um you know chromatography or fmri that
you at least look up on the Internet
what its purpose is okay that will help
a lot and then it was what they found
and there you can usually figure out
what they believe they found Anyway by
reading the figure headers right what
are you know figure one here's the
header that typically if it's an
experimental paper it will tell you what
they want you to to think they found and
then I tend to want to know the
conclusion of the study and then this is
really the key one and this is the one
that would really distinguish the high
performing students from the others
you have to go back at the end and ask
whether or not the conclusions the major
conclusions drawn in the paper are
really substantiated by what they found
and what they did and that involves some
thinking it involves really you know
spending some time thinking about what
what they identified now this isn't
something that anyone can do straight
off the bat it's a skill that you
develop over time and different papers
require different formats but those four
questions really form the Cornerstone of
teaching undergraduates and I think
graduate students as well of how to read
a paper and um again it's something that
can be cultivated
um and it's still how I approach papers
so what I do typically is I'll read
title abstract
ice usually then we'll skip to the
figures and see how much of it I can
digest without reading the text and then
go back and read the text but In
fairness journals great journals like
science like nature oftentimes will pack
so much information in the cell press
journals too into each figure and it's
coded with no definition of the acronyms
that almost always I'm into the
introduction and results within a couple
of minutes wondering what the hell This
Acronym is or that acronym is and it's
um it's just yeah it's just wild how
much
um how much nomenclature there really is
I can't remember was it you or was it
our friend Paul Conte when he was here
um who said that oh no I'm sorry it was
neither it was chair of Ophthalmology at
Stanford uh Dr Jeffrey Goldberg who is a
guest on the podcast recently who off
camera I think it was told us that if
you look at the total number of words
and terms that a physician leaving
Medical School owns in their mind and
their vocabulary it's the equivalent of
like 2 two additional full languages of
fluency beyond their native language so
you're trilingual at least I don't know
do you speak a language other than
English poorly okay so you're you're at
least trilingual and probably more so no
one is expected to be able to parse
these papers the first time through
without you know substantial training
yeah no I I I think that's a that's a
great format and you're absolutely right
I have a different way that I do it when
I'm familiar with the subject matter
versus when I'm not uh well again if I'm
reading papers that are something that I
know really well I can basically glean
everything I need to know from the
figures
um and then sometimes I'll just do a
quick skim on methods but I don't need
to read the discussion I don't need to
read the intro I don't need to read
anything else uh if it's something that
I know less about then I usually do
exactly what you say I try to start with
the figures
I usually end up generating more
questions like what what do you mean
what it how what is this how did they do
that and then I got to go back and read
methods typically and one of the other
thing that's probably worth mentioning
is a lot of papers these days have
supplemental information that are not
attached to the paper so
um you're amazed at how much stuff gets
put in the supplemental section and the
reason for that of course is that the
journals are very uh specific on the
format and length of a paper so a lot of
the times when you're submitting
something you know like if you want to
put any additional information in there
it can't go in the main article it has
to go in the supplemental figure so even
for this paper there were a couple of
the numbers I spouted off that I had to
pull out of the supplemental paper for
example when they did the sensitivity
analysis on the
um censoring versus non-censoring that
that was in the supplemental figure that
was actually not even in the paper we
presented
well should we change this other paper
yeah it's a very different sort of paper
it's an experimental paper where there's
a manipulation I must say I love love
love this paper and I don't often say
that about papers I'm so excited about
this paper for so many reasons but I
want to give a couple of caveats up
front first of all the paper is not
published yet
the only reason I was able to get this
paper is because it's on bioarchive
there's a new trend over the last I
would say five six years of people
posting the papers that they've
submitted to journals for peer review
online so that people can look at them
prior to those papers being peer
reviewed so there is a strong
possibility that the final version of
this paper which again we will provide a
link to is going to look different maybe
even quite a bit different than the one
that we're going to discuss nonetheless
there are a couple of things that make
me confident in the data that we're
about to talk about first of all
the group that published this paper is
really playing in their wheelhouse this
is what they do and they publish a lot
of really nice papers in this area
um I'm going to mispronounce
um her first name but I think it's
chaosi goo at
um who's at the econ School of Medicine
Mount Sinai runs a laboratory there
studying Addiction in humans and
um the first off author of the paper is
over Pearl this paper is wild and I'll
just give you a couple of the takeaways
first as a bit of a hook to hopefully uh
entice people into listening further
because this is an important paper
this paper basically addresses how our
beliefs about the drugs we take
impacts
how they
affect us at a real level not just at a
subjective level but at a biological
level so just to back up a little bit a
former guest on this podcast Dr Ali Crum
whose name is actually Aaliyah crumb but
she goes by Ali Crum talked about belief
effects belief effects are different
than Placebo effects
Placebo effects are really just category
effects it's okay I'm gonna give you
this pill Peter and I'm going to tell
you that this pill is molecule
x5952 and that it's going to make your
memory better and then I give you a
memory test right and your group
performs better than the people in the
control group who I give a pill to and I
say this is just a placebo or there are
other variants on this where people will
get a drug and you tell them it's
Placebo they'll get a placebo you tell
them it's drug it's it's a binary thing
it's an on or off thing you're either in
the drug group or the placebo group and
you're either told that you're getting
drug or Placebo and we know that Placebo
effects exist in fact one of the crueler
ones I was never the subject of this but
there was kind of lore in high school
that you know like kids would do this
mean thing it's a form of bullying I
really don't like it where you know they
get some kid at a party to drink
um alcohol-free beer and then that kid
would start acting drunk and then they'd
go gotcha you know it doesn't even have
alcohol in it now that's a mean joke
um and just reminds me of some of the
the uh the horrors of high school maybe
that's why I didn't go very often which
I also don't suggest but no it um it's a
mean joke but it speaks to the placebo
effect right and there's also a social
context effect
so Placebo effects are real
um we know this belief effects are
different belief effects are not a or b
Placebo or non Placebo belief effects
have a lot of knowledge to enrich
one's belief about a certain something
that can shift their Psychology and
Physiology one way or the other and I
think the best examples of these really
of these belief effects really do come
from alichrom's Lab in the psychology
department at Stanford although some of
this work she did prior to getting to
Stanford for instance if people are put
into a group where they watch A Brief
video just a few minutes of video about
how stress really limits our performance
let's say an archery or at mathematics
or at music or at public speaking and
then you test them in any of those
domains or other domains
in a stressful circumstance they perform
less well okay and we know they perform
less well because we're by virtue of a
heightened stress response you can
measure heart rate you can measure
stroke volume of the heart you can
measure um peripheral blood flow which
goes down when people are stressed
narrowing a vision Etc
you take a different group of people and
randomly assign them to another group
where now they're being told that stress
enhances performance
it mobilizes resources it Narrows your
vision such that you can perform tasks
better Etc et cetera and their
performance increases above a control
group that receives just useless
information or at least useless as it
relates to the task so in both cases by
the way the groups are being told the
truth stress can be depleting or it can
enhance performance but this is
different than Placebo because now it's
scaling according to the amount and the
type of information that they're getting
and can you give me a sense of magnitude
of benefit or detriment that one could
experience in a situation like the one
you just described yeah so it's it's
striking they're opposite in direction
so the stress gets us worse makes you
um let's say I think that if we were to
just put a rough percentage on this it
would be somewhere between 10 and 30
percent worse at performance than the
control group and stress is enhancing is
approximately equivalent Improvement so
they're in opposite directions even more
striking is the the studies that
um Ali's lab did and others looking at
for instance you give people a milkshake
you tell it's a high calorie milkshake
has a lot of nutrients and then you
measure ghrelin secretion in the blood
and ghrelin is a marker of hunger that
increases the longer it's been since
you've eaten and what you notice is that
suppresses ghrelin to a great degree and
for a long period of time you give
another group a shake you tell them it's
a low calorie Shake
that it's got some nutrients in it but
that doesn't have much fat not much
sugar Etc they drink the shape less
ghrelin's suppression and it's the same
shape and it's the same Shake
and satiety lines up with that also in
that study and then the third one which
is also pretty striking is they took
hotel workers they give them a short
tutorial or not informing them that
moving around during the day and
vacuuming and doing all that kind of
thing is great it helps you lower your
BMI which is great for your health you
get you incentivize them and then you
let them out into the wild of their
everyday job you measure their activity
levels the two groups don't differ
they're doing roughly the same test
leaning down cleaning out trash cans Etc
guess what the group that was informed
about the health benefits of exercise
lose 12 percent more weight
compared to the other group and no
difference in actual movement apparently
not now how could that be I mean
literally this was sparked by in Ali's
words you know
this was sparked by her graduate advisor
saying what if all the effects of
exercise are Placebo right like which is
which is not what anyone really believes
but it's just such a you know I love
that anecdote that Ali told us because
it just really speaks to how like really
smart people think they sit back and
they go yeah like exercise obviously has
benefits but like what if a lot of the
benefits are that you tell yourself it's
good for you and the Brain can actually
activate these these mechanisms in the
body and why wouldn't that be the case
because the nervous system extends
through both so so interesting so
interesting Okay so
fast forward to this study which is
really about belief effects not Placebo
effects and to make a long story short
we know that nicotine Vaped smoked
dipped or snuffed or these little Zin
pouches or taken in capsule form does
improve cognitive performance I'm not
suggesting people run out and start
doing any of those things I did a whole
episode on nicotine the delivery device
often will kill you some other way or is
bad for you but it causes
vasoconstriction which is also not good
for certain people but nicotine is
cognitive enhancing why well you have a
couple sites in the brain namely in the
basal forebrain nucleus basalus in the
back of the brain structures like Locus
ceruleus but also this what's called
it's got a funny name the
pedunculopontine nucleus which is this
nucleus in the in the the pons in the
back of the brain in the brain stem that
sends those little axon wires into the
thalamus the thalamus is a gateway for
sensory information and in the thalamus
the visual information the auditory
information
it has nicotinic receptors and when the
pedunculopontine nucleus releases
nicotine or when you ingest nicotine
what it does is it increases the signal
to noise of information coming in
through your senses so the Fidelity of
the signal that gets up to your cortex
which is your conscious perception of
those senses is increased and how much
endogenous nicotine do we produce oh
um well it's going to be acetylcholine
bonding to nicotinic receptors I see
we're not making nicotine we're not just
binding so this is a this is a nicotinic
acetylcholine receptor right of which
there are at least seven and probably
like 14 subtypes but
um so right they're called nicotinic
receptors in an annoying way in the same
way that cannabinoid receptors are
called cannabinoid receptors but then
everyone thinks oh you know those
receptors are there so because we're
supposed to smoke pot or those receptors
are there because we're supposed to
ingest nicotine no the drugs that were
used
that's right right exactly receptor was
named after the drug and so the
important thing to know is that whether
or not it's basal forebrain or
predunculopontine nucleus or Locus
ceruleus that at least in the brain
because we're not talking about muscle
where acetylcholine does something else
via nicotinic receptors there in general
it just tends to be a signal to noise
enhancer and so for the non-engineering
types out there no problem signal to
noise just imagine I'm talking right now
and there's a lot of static in the
background there are two ways for you to
be able to hear me more clearly we can
reduce the static or I can increase the
Fidelity the the volume and the clarity
of what I'm saying okay
um for instance and that's really what
acetylcholine does that's why when
people smoke a cigarette they get that
boost of nicotine and they just feel
clear it really works the other thing
that happens is the thalamus
sends information to a couple of places
first of all it sends information to the
reward centers of the brain the
mesolympic reward pathway that releases
dopamine and typically when nicotine is
increased in our system dopamine goes up
that's one of the reasons why nicotine
is reinforcing we just like it it's a we
seek it out I've done beautiful
experiments with honeybees even where
you know you put nicotine on certain
plants or it comes from certain plants
and they'll forage there more you get
you know them kind of like buzzed that
was upon bad pun
um in any event
there's also an output from this thing
the thalamus to the ventromedial
prefrontal cortex which is an area of
the forebrain that really allows us to
limit our focus and our attention for
sake of learning it allows us to pay
attention this is the circuit you talked
about this in your fantastic podcast on
stimulants
yeah on ADH so ADHD typically ADHD drugs
so things like Adderall Vyvanse
methamphetamine for that matter
um Ritalin yeah why it's
counter-intuitive that a stimulant would
be a treatment for someone with
difficulty focusing yeah in young kids
who have difficulty focusing if you give
them something they love they're like a
laser and the reason is that
ventromedial prefrontal cortex circuit
can engages when the kid is interested
and engaged but kids with ADD ADHD tend
to have a hard time engaging their mind
for other types of tasks and other types
of tasks are important for getting
through life and it turns out that
giving those stimulant drugs in many
cases can enhance the function of that
circuit and it can strengthen so that
ideally the kids don't need the drugs in
the long run although that's not often
the way that it plays out and there are
other ways to get at this you know
there's now a big battle out there you
know is ADHD real is it not real of
course it's real does every kid need
ADHD meds no are there other things like
nutrition more play time outside Etc
that can help improve their symptoms
without drugs yes is the combination of
all those things together
known to be most beneficial yes are the
dosages given too high
and generally should be you know
titrated down maybe some kids need a lot
some kids need a little I probably just
you know gained and lost a few enemies
there so um the point is that
um these circuits are hardwired circuits
sorry one other question Andrew
um if my memory serves correctly doesn't
nicotine potentially have a calming
effect as well and that seems a bit
counterintuitive to the focusing one or
the is it a dose effect or a timing
effect how does that work yeah it's a
dosing effect so the interesting thing
about nicotine is that it can enhance
focus in the brain but in the periphery
it actually provides some muscle
relaxation so it's kind of the perfect
drug if you think about it again
um it's it was reflecting on this how
when we were growing up people would
smoke on plane they had a smoking
section on the plane you know people
smoked all the time and now hardly
anyone smokes but for all the obvious
reasons but yeah it provides that really
Ideal Balance between being alert but
being mellow and relaxed in the body so
um hence it's reinforcing properties
okay this study is remarkable because
what they did is they had people come
into the laboratory
they gave them
a vape pen these are these are smokers
so these are experienced smokers
typically there's a washout before they
come in so they're not smoking for a bit
so they can clear their system of
nicotine and they measure how long is
that needed um typically it's a couple
of days oh okay yeah um which must be
miserable for those people you can't
have Nicorette gum or anything no
nothing they must be dying and I wonder
how many cheat but they can measure they
measure an oxide right they measure
carbon dioxide and they're measuring
nicotine in the blood as well so they do
a good job there so then what they do is
they have them vape and they're vaping
either a low medium or high dose of
nicotine the dosages don't really matter
because tolerance varies Etc and then
they are putting them into a functional
magnetic resonance imaging machine so
where they can look at it's really blood
flow it's really hemodynamic response
for those who want to know it's the
oxygen it's the ratio of the oxygenated
to deoxygenated blood because when blood
blood will flow to neurons that are
active to give it oxygen and then it's
deoxygenated and then there's a change
in what's called The Bold signal so fmri
when you see these like hot spots in the
brain is really just looking at blood
flow and then there's some interesting
physics around and I'll probably get
this wrong but I'll take an attempt at
it so that I get beat up a little bit by
the physicists and Engineers do you
remember the right hand rule yep right
okay so do I have this right uh correct
um the right hand rule if you put your
thumb out with your first with your
index finger your middle finger your
thumb facing up I think that the thumb
represents the charge the direction of
the charge right and then isn't the
electromagnetic field is the downward
facing figure and then it's uh do I have
that right
um
okay so someone will look it up but what
you do is when you put a person's head
in this big magnet and then you pulse
the magnet what happens is the
oxygenated and deoxygenated blood
it interacts with the magnetic field
differently and that difference in
Signal can be detected and you can see
that in the form of activated brain
areas yeah I mean MRI all works by
proton detection so presumably there's a
difference in the proton signal when you
have high oxygen versus low oxygen
concentration yeah yeah that's right
um and what they'll do is they'll pulse
with the magnet because my understanding
is that
um and this is definitely getting beyond
my expertise but that the the spin
orientation of the protons then it's
it's going to relax back at a different
rate as well so by the relaxation at a
different rate you can also get
um not just resting state activation
like oh look at a banana what areas of
the brain light up but you can look at
connectivity between areas and how one
area is driving the activity of another
area so very very powerful technique
um so what they do is they put people in
a scanner and then you'll like this
because what are the what are the
limitations of of fmri in terms of I
mean how fine is the resolution I mean
where are the blind spots of the
technique
so resolution you can get down to sub
centimeter they talk about it always in
these paper as a voxels which are these
little cubic pixels
um things
um uh you know Sub sub centimeter but
you're not going to get down to
millimeter okay
um there are a number of little
compounds that maybe we won't go into
now that have been basically worked out
over the last 10 years by doing the
following you can't just give somebody a
stimulus compared to nothing
I'll just tell you the experiment it was
discovered for instance that when
someone would move their right hand
because when you're in the MRI and just
went for one of these recently for a
clinical not a problem but just for a
diagnostic scan you're leaning back and
you and you can move your right hand a
bit and they would see an area in motor
cortex lighting up but what they noticed
was that the area corresponding to the
left hand was also lighting up
so what you really have to do is you
have to look at resting state how much
are they lighting up yeah and then
subtract that out so now you'll always
see resting state versus activation
State yeah wasn't there a really funny
study done as a spoof maybe a decade ago
that put a dead salmon into an MRI
machine and did an effect like they did
an fmri of a dead salmon that
demonstrated like some interesting
signal no I didn't know that but but we
got to find this one for the for the
show notes we should do one of these
wild papers ones there's there are
papers of you know people putting don't
do this folks putting elephants on LSD
that were published in science and
things like like crazy experiments we
should definitely do a crazy experiments
Journal Club
um
in any event you can get a sense of
which brain areas are active and when
with fairly high spatial resolution
fairly high and pretty good temporal
resolution on the order of hundreds of
milliseconds not but it's not Ultra
Ultra fast because a lot of neural
transmission is happening on the you
know tens of milliseconds especially
when you're in talking about auditory
processing okay so they put people into
the scanner and then they they give them
a essentially a task that's designed to
engage the thalamus known to engage the
thalamus reward centers and the
ventromedial prefrontal cortex and it's
a very simple game you'll like this
because um you have a background in
finance you let people watch a market
you know okay here's the stock market or
you could say or the price of peas it
doesn't really matter it goes up it goes
down and they're looking at squiggle
line then it stops and then they have
the option but they have to pick one
option they're either going to invest a
certain number of the 100 units that
you've given them
or they can short it they can say oh
it's going to go down and try and make
money on the on the prediction it's
going to go down you could explain
shorting better than I could for sure
so depending on whether or not they get
the prediction right or wrong
they get more points or they lose points
and they're going to be rewarded in real
money at the end of the experiment
so this is going to engage this type of
circuitry now remember
these groups were given a vape pen prior
to this where they've Vaped what they
were told is either a low medium or high
dose of nicotine and they do this task
the goal is not to get them to perform
better on the task the goal is to engage
the specific brain areas that are
relevant to this kind of error and
reward type circuits and we know that
this task does that so that includes the
thalamus that includes the mesolympic
reward pathway and dopamine it includes
the ventral medial prefrontal cortex
first of all they measure nicotine in
the blood
they are measuring how much people Vaped
they were very careful about this one of
the nice things about the vape pen for
the sake of experiment and not
recommending people Vape but they can
measure how much nicotine is left in the
vape pen before after they can measure
how long they inhaled how long they held
it in there's a lot that you can do
that's harder to do with a cigarette
okay
they measured people's belief as to
whether or not they got low medium or
high amounts of nicotine and if they
were told they were told they got either
this is a low amount a medium amount or
a high amount
and then of course they looked at brain
area activation during this task and
what they found was very straightforward
sorry they were all given the same
amount yes this is this is the sneak I
was going to offer it as a punch line
but that's okay no I think that the the
cool thing about this experiment is that
the subjects are unaware that they all
got the exact same amount of relatively
low nicotine containing vape pen so they
they basically and they're measuring it
from their bloodstream so they all have
fairly low levels of nicotine but one
group was told you got a lot one group
was told you got a medium amount and the
other was told you got a little bit
now a number of things happen but the
most interesting things are the
following first of all people's
subjective feeling of
being on the drug matches what they were
told so if they were told hey this is a
high amount of nicotine like yeah it
feels like a high amount of nicotine and
these are experienced smokers if it was
a medium amount they're like man that
feels like a medium amount if it's a low
amount they think it was a low amount
now that's perhaps not so surprising
that's you just that's true Placebo yeah
but
if you look at the activation of the
thalamus
in the exact regions where you would
predict acetylcholine transmission to
impact the function of the thalamus so
these include areas like What's called
the centromedian nucleus the ventral
posterior nucleus the names that really
don't matter but these are areas
involved in attention
it scales with what they thought they
got in the vape pen meaning if you were
told that you got a low amount of
nicotine you got a little bit of
activation in these areas if you were
told that you got a medium amount of
nicotine and that's what you Vaped then
you had medium amounts or moderate
amounts of activation and if you were
told you you got high amounts of
nicotine you got a high degree of
activation and the performance on the
task Believe It or Not scales with it
someone
so keep in mind everyone got the exact
same amount of nicotine in reality so
here the belief effect isn't just
changing what one subjectively
experiences oh this is the effect of
high nicotine or low nicotine it
actually is changing the way that the
brain responds to the belief
and that to me is absolutely wild now
there are a couple of other things that
could have confounded this first of all
it could have been that if you believe
you got a lot of nicotine you're just
faster where you're reading the lines
better or your response time to hit the
button is quicker you know I tell you
you have a drug that's going to improve
reaction time you might believe that
about nicotine and so you're quicker on
the trigger and you're getting they have
a different activation more activation
um there could be they rule that out
they also rule out the possibility how
to bid rule that out by looking at rates
of of pressing and there was nothing and
in sensory areas of the brain that would
would
um represent that kind of difference
they don't see that the other thing that
um is very clear is that the connection
between the thalamus and the ventral
medial prefrontal cortex that pathway
scales in the most beautiful way such
that people that were told they had
smoked a low or Vaped a low amount of
nicotine got a subtle activation of that
pathway people that were told that they
got a moderate amount of nicotine got a
more robust activation of that pathway
and the people that were told that they
got a high amount of nicotine in The
Vape Pen saw a very robust activation of
the thalamus to this ventral prefrontal
cortical pathway now of course
this is all happening under the hood of
the skull simply on the basis of what
they were told and what they believe and
technically the fmri is showing the
activation of those two areas and that's
how you can infer the strength of that
connection that's right there's a
separate method called diffuser tensor
Imaging which was developed I believe
out of the group in Minnesota Minnesota
has a very robust group in terms of
neuroimaging
um that can measure activation and fiber
Pathways this is not that but you can
look at the timing of activation and
it's a known what we call monosynaptic
Pathway so we haven't talked so much
about figures here but um I guess if we
were going to look at any one figure
um and I can just describe it for the
audience that's not paying doesn't have
the figure in front of them the
uh let's see the the most
um
probably the most important figure is
figure two remember I said I like to
read the titles of figures which is that
the belief about nicotine strength
induced a dose dependent response in the
thalamus basically if you and figure 2B
um can tell you if they believe that
they got more nicotine that's uh that's
essentially the response that they that
they saw so if you look or sorry panel e
if you look at the belief rating
as a function of the estimate
in the thalamus of what how much
activation there was it's a it's a mess
when you look at all the dots at once
but if you just separate it out by high
medium and low you run the statistics
what you find is that there's a gradual
increase
but a legitimate one from low to medium
to high in other words if I tell you
this is a high dose of nicotine your
brain will react as if it's a high dose
of nicotine now what they didn't do was
give people zero nicotine I was about to
say there's a control that's missing
yeah right yeah so what they didn't do
is give people zero nicotine and then
tell them uh this is a high amount of
nicotine sort of the equivalent of the
cruel High School experiment no alcohol
but then the the kid acts drunk now in
the uh in the
High School example it's unclear whether
or not the kid actually felt drunk or
not
um it's unclear whether or not they had
been drunk previously if they even knew
what it would be like to feel drunk Etc
and there's the social context what I
find just outrageous and outrageously
interesting about this study is simply
that what we are told about the dose of
a drug changes the way that our
physiology responds to the dose of the
drug and in and in my understanding this
is the first study to ever look at dose
dependence of belief effects
right to really and why would that be
important well for almost every study of
drugs you look at a dose-dependent curve
you look at zero low-dose medium dose
high dose and here they
they clearly are seeing a dose dependent
response
simply to the understanding of what they
expect the drug ought to do
in other words you can bypass
pharmacology somewhat right now look at
figure 2B am I reading this correctly so
it's got
um four bars on there you've got the
group who we're told they got a low dose
the group who was told they got a medium
dose the group that was told they had a
high dose and then these healthy
controls right who presumably were
non-smokers who were just put in the
machine that's right yeah yeah this is
measuring parameter estimate what is
that referring to
um their ability to play the the the the
trading game uh the parameter estimate
is the is the activation
um reward related activities from
independent to almost mask right so what
they're doing is they're just saying if
we just look at the thalamus what is the
level of activation I see so this
suggests that the only statistical
difference was between
the low and the high that's right and
nobody else was statistically different
that's right but that's not the whole
story no that's not the whole story so
when you look at the output from the
thalamus to the ventromedial prefrontal
cortex that's where you start to
identify the is that figure four uh that
is yes so this is where you see
um so figure 4B
if you look at parameter estimates so
this is the degree of activation between
the thalamus and the ventromedial
prefrontal cortex and it's called the
instructed belief you can see that
there's a low medium and high scatter of
dots for each and that each one of those
is significant so isn't it interesting
that
at the thalamus which is and you'll
you'll immediately appreciate my
stupidity when it comes to Neuroscience
which is more proximate to the
nicotinamide or nicotine that
nicotinamide what do you call it the
nicotine acetylcholine receptor
you have a lower difference of signal
strength and somehow that got Amplified
as it made its way forward in the brain
yeah does that surprise you it is
surprising and it surprised them as well
that the interpretation they give again
as we're talking about before important
to match their conclusions against what
they actually found which is what we're
doing here the interpretation that they
give is that it doesn't take much
nicotinic receptor occupancy in the
thalamus to activate this pathway but
they too were surprised that they could
not detect a raw difference in the
activation of Thalamus but in terms of
its output
to the prefrontal cortex that's when
because that figure
4B is more convincing than figure two
because even figure 2E if you read the
fine print the r the correlation
coefficient is 0.27 that's it's not that
strong right it's weak so at the
thalamus it's kind of like yeah there
might be a signal by the way this goes
back to our earlier discussion there
could be a huge signal here and we're
underpowered how many subjects were in
this this you wouldn't have a lot of
subjects in this experiment yeah this is
no you it and this just speaks to the
general challenge of doing this kind of
work it's hard to get a lot of people in
and through the scanner yeah it's
expensive it's expensive uh we have to I
should know this but we can um we can go
back to the but you can sort of just
look at the number of dots on here I
mean it's in the low tens right it's
like 40 30 something like that it's not
so it's possible you do this with a
Danish study yeah you do this with a
thousand people this could all be
statistically significant right it was
um so they talk about this you know
based on this we estimated that an N of
20 n a sample size in each belief
condition the final sample would provide
90 power hour to detect an effect of
this magnitude at an alpha of 0.0 0.5
and a two-tailed
um test okay so that's that's them
referring to what we just talked about
which is the power we believe at 90
confidence to get an alpha of 0.05 which
means we'll want to be 95 confidence we
need 60 people 20 per group right yeah
but if the difference is smaller than
what they expected they'll miss out on
some of the significance which that
looks like they're missing between the
medium and High group yep and I too was
surprised that
um they did not see a difference in the
between the medium and the High group
but they did in the output of the
thalamus I was also surprised that they
didn't see a difference this is kind of
interesting in its own right if figure
three talks about their belief about
nicotine strength did not modulate the
reward response the dopamine response
how was that measured also just in fmri
yeah exactly so if you look at figure 3B
other people can't see it but basically
oh yeah what you'll see is that there's
no difference between these different
groups
um in terms of the amount amount of
activation in these reward Pathways if
people got a low medium or high amount
of nicotine now that actually could be
leveraged I believe if somebody were
trying to quit nicotine for instance and
they were going to do that by
progressively reducing the amount of
nicotine that they were taking but you
told them that it was the same amount
one from one day to the next you could
Whittle it down to presumably to a low
amount before taking it to zero and if
they believed it to be a greater amount
then it might actually not uh disrupt
their reward Pathways meaning they would
feel
um presumably they'd feel rewarded by
whatever nicotine they were bringing in
what would be your prediction if this
experiment were repeated but it was done
exactly the same way with non-smokers
well one thing that's sort of um
interesting you asked about art
potential sources of of artifact
problems with fmri one of the challenges
that they know in the study was you have
to stay very still in the in the machine
but the subjects were constantly
coughing because they're smokers so okay
so presumably the data would be higher
Fidelity started chuckling at that one
but I I was like I had to read that one
twice oh that makes sense like there's
smokers they're coughing they can't stay
still so movement artifact
um but in all seriousness I think that
for people that are naive to nicotine
even a small amount of nicotine is
likely to get this pathway activated to
such a great degree sort of like the
first time effect of pretty much any
drug but I wonder if they would be more
or less susceptible to the belief system
yeah that's a really good question right
because they have no prior to compare it
to they have no Pleasant they have no
experience to compare it to with respect
to the obviously beneficial effects of
nicotine that the smokers are well used
to so this is the the poor kid that got
duped into thinking the non-alcoholic
beer was at alcohol though they're
actually the winner we know because I
did an episode and alcohol alcohol is
bad for you so in the end that kid wins
and the other ones lose poetic justice
but um that kid having never been
actually drunk before
presumably I would feel like they're
being more susceptible that's my guess
as well so you know my glee for this
experiment is not or this paper rather
is not because I think it's the be all
end-all or it's a perfect experiment I
just think it's so very cool that
they're starting to explore dose
dependence of belief because that has
all sorts of implications I mean
um use your imagination folks whether or
not we're talking about
um a drug we're talking about a
behavioral intervention we're talking
about a vaccine and I'm not referring to
any one specific vaccine I'm just
talking to vaccines generally I'm
talking about
psychoactive drugs I'm talking about
illicit drugs I'm talking about
antidepressants I'm talking about all
the sorts of drugs we were talking about
before metformin Etc just throw our arms
around all of it
what we believe about the effects of a
drug presumably in addition to what we
believe about how much we're taking and
what those effects ought to be clearly
are impacting at least the way that our
brain reacts to to those drugs yeah it's
very interesting I mean when you
consider how many drugs that have
peripheral effects
um or peripheral outputs begin with
Central issues so again I think the
glp-1 agonists are such a great example
yeah yeah
um
you know I don't think anybody fully
understands exactly how they're working
but it's hard to argue that they're
impacting that the glp-1 analog is is
having a central impact it's doing
something in the brain that is leading
to a reduction of appetite we believe
that yeah yeah and I think the mouse
data point to different areas of the
hypothalamus that are related to satiety
that that say it's at least possible
yeah I mean that you know there's no
quicker way to make a mouse overeat or
under eat than by lesioning it's
hypothalamus depending on where you do
so so presumably these drugs work there
but again it speaks to like what do you
need to believe in order for that to be
the case have they done Placebo trials
there where people get something and
they're told I mean of course those
drugs have all been tested via Placebo
and the placebo groups you know don't do
anywhere near as well that's how we know
that there's activity of the drug but
but again there's you know that's a
little bit different than being told you
are absolutely getting it right because
in the rcts you're just told you might
be getting it you might not be getting
it so it's not quite the same as this
experiment this experiment is is one
level up where you're being told no
you're absolutely getting it you're just
getting different doses of it yeah to
take this to maybe the ADHD realm let's
say a kid has been on ADHD meds for a
while and the parents for whatever
reason the physician decide they want to
cut back on the dosage
um but if they were to tell the kid it's
the same dosage they've always been
taking and it's had a certain positive
effect for them
according to the results at least in
this paper which are not definitive but
are interesting
the lower dose may be as effective
simply on the basis of belief and and
this is the part that makes it so cool
to me is that and it's not a kid
tricking themselves or the parents
tricking the kid
so much as the brain activation is
corresponding to the belief right so
that's where this is this is why because
it's done in the brain I think we can
um you know it gets to these kind of
abstract uh nearly mystical but not
quite mystical aspects of belief effects
which is that you know your brain is a
prediction making machine it's a data
interpretation machine but it's clear
that one of the more important pieces of
data are your beliefs about how these
things impact you uh so it's not that
this bypasses physiology people aren't
deluding themselves the thalamus is
behaving as if it's a high dose when
it's the same dose as the low dose group
wild yeah I mean I think of the
implications for example with blood
pressure right like we don't really
understand essential hypertension which
is the majority of people walking around
with high blood pressure it's unclear
ideology
um so lots of people being treated how
do we know that the belief system about
it can't be changed and
um yeah this is this is I don't know
this is eye-opening yeah it's cool stuff
and Ali crumb is on to some other really
cool stuff like for instance um just to
highlight where these belief effects are
starting to show up if you tell a group
that the side effects of a drug that
they're taking are evidence that the
drug really works for the purpose that
they're taking it even though those side
effects are kind of annoying people
report the experiences less awful and
they report more relief from the primary
symptoms that they're trying to Target
so our belief about what side effects
are that's so interesting can really
impact how quickly and how
um compatible we feel about how quickly
a drug Works excuse me and how
compatible we feel that drug is with our
entire life so maybe if we call them
something else like not side effects but
like additional benefits or something
it's kind of crazy and you don't want to
lie to people obviously but you also
don't want to send yourself in the
opposite direction which is reading the
list of side effects of a drug and then
developing all of those side effects
um when and then maybe later coming to
the understanding that some of those
were raised through belief effects
um we definitely see that that's the
nocebo effect right that's that's the
one we see a lot uh you know with all
sorts of drugs and it's tough because
you know how do you how do you know
which is which and I think there are
some people who are really impacted by
that and it makes it very difficult for
them to take any sort of pharmacologic
agent because they basically
they can't help but incur every possible
side effect
um is it or is it true that medical
students often will start developing the
symptoms of the different diseases that
they're learning about is that true well
you know I'll tell you I do think that
in medical school you start to
you start to think of the zebras more
than the horses all the time you know
like you know what I'm referring to
right now you know you see Footprints
you you see hoof prints you should think
of horses but of course medical students
you only think of the zebras there are
some really funny things in medical
school like there are certain conditions
that you spend so much time thinking
about that you have a very warped sense
of their prevalence uh like in medical
school there's this condition called
sarcoidosis like we I feel like we never
stop talking about sarcoidosis I've seen
like three cases in my life right like
it's just not that common
um does it provide a great teaching tool
or something I don't know like I just
some of these things I don't know uh how
much time did we spend talking about
cytus and verses this is when people
embryologically have a reversed rotation
and everything in their body is flipped
literally everything is flipped so their
heart is on their right side their liver
is on the left side their appendix is on
the left side like and so I'm not making
this up how common is this I've never
seen it okay I was thinking about boxing
in the liver shot like you could easily
be going for the wrong side of the body
no I swear to God like as a medical
student if you were told someone had
left-sided lower quadrant pain to which
the answer is almost assuredly like they
have diverticulitis you'd think they
could have appendicitis in the context
of cytus and versus like the fact that I
would even register in the top 10 things
that it could possibly be wow but yes
you just have a totally warped sense of
what's out there oh man
well um
this has been Pure Pleasure for me I
don't know about yeah I don't know about
our listeners but for me this is among
the things that I just Delight in and
and even more so because you're the one
across the table for me teaching me
about these incredible findings and and
the gaps in those findings which are
equally incredible because they're
equally important to know about yeah so
let's do this again in Austin absolutely
next time on your home court very well
and bring a little bit of that due if
you've got it oh yeah yeah I'll bring a
low medium and high low medium and
higher
thanks Peter you're the best thanks sir
thank you for joining me for today's
Journal Club discussion with Dr Peter
attia if you're learning from and or
enjoying this podcast please subscribe
to our YouTube channel that's a terrific
zero cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review if you have questions
for me or comments about the podcast or
guests that you'd like me to consider
hosting on the huberman Lab podcast
please put those in the comments section
on YouTube I do read all the comments
please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast not so
much on today's episode but on many
previous episodes of The huberman Lab
podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
enhancing sleep for hormone support and
for Focus the huberman Lab podcast has
partnered with momentous supplements if
you'd like to access the supplements
discussed on the huberman Lab podcast
you can go to live momentous spelled ous
so it's livemomentis.com huberman and
you can also receive 20 off again that's
live momentous spelled ous.com slash
huberman if you haven't already
subscribed to our neural network
newsletter our neural network newsletter
is a completely zero cost monthly
newsletter that includes summaries of
podcast episodes as well as protocols
that is short PDFs describing for
instance tools to improve sleep tools to
improve neuroplasticity we talk about
deliberate cold exposure Fitness various
aspects of mental health again all
completely zero cost and to sign up you
simply go to hubermanlab.com go over to
the menu in the corner scroll down to
newsletter and provide your email we do
not share your email with anybody if
you're not already following me on
social media I am huberman lab on all
platforms so that's Instagram Twitter
threads LinkedIn and Facebook and at all
of those places I talk about science and
science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content of the
huberman Lab podcast but much of which
is distinct from the content of the
huberman Lab podcast again it's huberman
lab on all social media platforms thank
you one again for joining me for today's
Journal Club discussion with Dr Peter
attia and last but certainly not least
thank you for your interest in science
[Music]